this show is brought to you by blue
apron
check out this week's menu and get your
first meals for first three meals for
free with blue apron you also get free
shipping when you go to blueapron.com
joey that's blueapron.com joey to get
your first three meals for free with
free shipping the show is also brought
to you by texture
go to texture.com joey right now and
download the free texture app which is
going to give you and they're giving a
free trial at texture.com joey it's
going to give you immediate entry to the
top magazines including back issues and
bonus video content start banjoing for
free at texture.com
oh [ __ ]
when we start with spanish music it's
gonna be [ __ ] dangerous
a little song from narcos that we've
been playing for [ __ ] three years on
this thing only the live version
this is when chill was solo on his own
music but he was still on the final
label but who gives a [ __ ]
it's the church of what's happening now
[ __ ] going into you smooth
september 4th
kick that leap kick that lead
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
when we go into something like that
smooth it's all over for you
[ __ ]
greetings happy labor day uncle joey
diaz with his main [ __ ] lisa and
my main little brother here troy conrad
what's happening gentlemen hey how was
the weekend
oh i had a fun weekend watched
speaking of this like the music on on
that is great just like do you ever
especially in l.a
whenever like i get like a a [ __ ] up
traffic thing or if someone calls and i
get distracted i'll just end up on like
mexican music or some some like southern
american music and it's just like i'll
just find myself listening to it and i
have no idea what they're saying or
what's happening it doesn't really
matter but it just it just and it all
sounds similar but just spirited oh yeah
you can always
you should feel the music in like your
soul it's a quantity saying no yeah it's
true sometimes if you feel it it could
be anything they don't even know that
you don't even need to know the [ __ ]
words
you don't even need to know the words
you know what the [ __ ] he's saying
through his music if you really put that
song on over and over and over
then you'll figure out one word then
maybe two and then you got it [ __ ]
down now you're singing a song in a
different language who's better than you
you get arrested in [ __ ] albania you
know the song of the hottest singer
you're [ __ ] american you know
albanian music you know you're gonna see
splash
with john candy one of the greatest yeah
how he gets the chick out of the tub
is he brings his brother but they're
sweets
and also the guy starts talking to him
in swedish and john candy just tells him
the swede line
and [ __ ] on the walk-in tom hanks
asking what you say to him
and he goes i told him uh he goes any
fine connoisseur knows that all the
best porn is made in sweden
you know and i'm [ __ ] dying right
he goes
he goes uh i said to him hey malik you
know whatever the [ __ ]
uh who's [ __ ] the i don't know
exactly the line i know people gonna get
pissed at me because it's a classic
movie he's like who's gonna [ __ ] her or
whatever yeah and the guy laughs in
english and you know the swedish guard
laughs so
you never know what you learned from
what you're listening it could be
anything you know some about the culture
it's uh it's the great connector it's
really weird if you're a fan of the
beatles you know what their music
changed and for an album when they went
to india they went somewhere and they
were playing [ __ ] harps and
there's one album i don't revolution
maybe don't quote me again
that they went over and took that music
and applied it to some of their songs
and it worked out perfectly because if
the music's good it all makes sense
it'll all make sense like rap and
[ __ ]
aerosmith that time you know run dmc i
wasn't i wasn't a big fan of that but it
did do something
it did do something and let you know
anybody could do it and it turned look
at what happened 10 years later 15 20
years later a guy by the name of kid
rock [ __ ] shows up doing that [ __ ] so
it's uh music could always be [ __ ]
merged troy conrad is a buddy of mine
that he had to refresh my memory how he
met i was under the impression
i didn't know nothing about comedy or
nothing i thought you were like a
producer guy
that and you were like one of the
producers on what's his name show on set
list oh you thought it was with the
green room with green for some reason i
thought you were like one of the
producers on the green room
and there's a lot of guys that you know
eric uh abrams yeah i have 10 friends
that they just do things in l.a yeah one
day you go shoot a movie and then they
on the [ __ ] movie set one day and
sometimes they're taking pictures
sometimes it really doesn't matter and i
i kind of appreciate that sometimes
i kind of like that when people do that
because what you're telling me is that
you're making a living [ __ ]
yeah you're making a living [ __ ] you're
putting it together one way or another
uh what's the kid from the store he's
like dog [ __ ] jeremiah watkins jeremy
walker he's unbelievable he's like dog
[ __ ] he's everywhere he's on this show
that show why because he put hustle in
yeah you can't get mad at jeremiah
watkins at all because those are the
kids that don't always work in this town
he's got the hustle yeah but so do you
no yeah well look i like doing i'm
always involved in all kinds of
different stuff right but i'm i'm just
in that that weird creative world but i
just like what's important to me is
doing stuff that matters instead of uh
making a living and doing something that
i hate and and if it's you know what i
mean like going like i don't do the
reality tv thing and all that stuff
because that's to me that's not i can't
be happy with that at the end of the day
so if i'm taking pictures if i'm making
a movie if i'm uh producing a show
creating a show that's that's what i
that's where i want to be so it's hard
to say what i do because it's [ __ ] a
little bit all over the place but man i
love it and it's all it's all rooted in
the comedy world because that's my world
now we always have conversations you're
a fan of the pirate jesus christ i love
the show you left something in here like
a piece of chocolate or something
jesus christ christ
he left a piece of chocolate in the god
damn bun on the inside i had some crazy
ideas what can i say
oh my god no i didn't
this is the chocolate from the mushroom
or somebody's lung or a piece of [ __ ]
blue
apron i know what the [ __ ] it is
you brought that blue apron
i you know i thought you were on that
and then you
guys like you stay 50 feet away from me
like nice guys like you just [ __ ]
stay the [ __ ] away from me they're like
you know what joey's trouble he's gonna
touch me with that thc finger
something's gonna happen i'm gonna crash
my car so you always approach me you're
always a sweet guy
and deep down inside i'm still a crazy
new yorker like i have no idea when
people approach me so for like a year
you would come up to me go hey i got
this show and i go what the [ __ ] is he
talking about oh yeah you know
i called you the other day and i tried
to explain to you
people come to talk to me at night like
unless you call me at home and go hey
we're going to talk [ __ ] business
tonight about my show okay yeah but if
you come up to me unexpectedly like i
look at you people said to me joey that
night i went up to you you looked at me
like because i'm [ __ ] a i'm coming
down off this [ __ ] stage thing or i'm
about to go up so my head's somewhere
completely different oh yeah somebody
got mad at me one night i was taking
pictures of the guy she came over she
goes hey can you talk to me about the
show i go hold on i'll go over there
when the guy took 40 minutes by the time
i got over there she was gone next day i
got a hate mail on my facebook so i had
a big paying gig for you go [ __ ]
yourself you're rude well i'm gonna tell
these people to go [ __ ] themselves
because you want to talk to me about a
gig this is a surprise to me like
it's just crazy sometimes where my head
is at night plus i'm thinking about my
daughter and my wife and we're gonna
move and the special yeah and the cats
and lee and that you got all these
thoughts going through your [ __ ] head
and at the end of the night it's like
people come up to me like you want to
get high no
if you know what i was going through
right now you wouldn't want to get high
either yeah because up laurel canyon how
[ __ ] my head going upward my head
explodes with all the thoughts not to
mention about my set
yeah i'm thinking about my set that's
the closest i'll remember once i get
over cold water it's over i'm thinking
about where to stop
who's got rolling papers
you know then i go into whatever and i'm
fine for a little while do you ever have
those times where somebody's talking to
you where you literally have zero
seconds to go on stage so you haven't
even thought about like what you're
gonna say and you walk on stage because
you were just in some conversation you
ever have that
sometimes the conversation helps me i
got to be honest with you sometimes
i like when somebody comes up to me and
annoys me
that makes sense no i pray for that i
pray for somebody come up to me that i
know
with a stupid question that knows me but
he's all [ __ ] up because what happens
is people who know me them too at night
they get [ __ ] up like i have a friend
that constantly that's a comedian a
well-known comedian
he only calls me saturday nights at 9 30
to say what you're doing how your week
is going i'm like listen where the [ __ ]
do you think i am yeah guess what last
night he didn't call me so today i
called him i go i just want to tell you
last night was the first saturday in
four weeks she didn't [ __ ] call me
i'll be home for two weeks he'll never
call he'll call me as soon as i get on
the [ __ ] plane they go hey you want
to go eat lunch i just told you a month
ago my dates
it's [ __ ] crazy so the mind listen
i understand a lot of people because i
know what i'm going through
i know when
you have all this [ __ ] on your plate and
people really can't grasp people have no
idea
how to grab away you i look at somebody
and i can tell they're in deep thought i
look at somebody and i can tell what's
kind of going on
if it's a good time to talk to them
especially if i'm selling you know
there's always [ __ ] something that's
why when lee comes from he goes hey
these people contacted us i go whoa
let's take a step back take a breath
and go in there with a clear mind
i've noticed in dealing like starting my
own business and then just in dealing
with people who are working by
themselves
and i did it a lot when i was really new
at it
is they try to oversell sometimes so
they get really excited and like even
after you say yes like yeah but it's
gonna be great because of this and like
i already said yeah and then they keep
going and going and it really you said
something like i've we've been to a i
you hear it a lot in l.a i'm going to a
meeting i haven't really been to any
i've been to like two meetings both with
you joey and i'm always like because i
don't i don't want to
talk out of bounds i'm like what should
i say and you're like just let them talk
yeah like there's no reason to talk
first and like so just it's it was a
very it was a very uh
like it's important to learn that
because you don't want to go to that big
meeting and overtalk you see it if
you've ever been to a meeting where
somebody's out of line
you [ __ ] feel it in the room you're
like jesus christ what is this guy tamed
down somebody tame him down
it's not good
it embarrasses me i went to one in
january i met a guy at a christmas party
that was trying to sell me that stuff
again lee
a year later nobody's using
that [ __ ] with the viral view of your
podcast or you could see the corner oh
and he took me to lunch and it was just
a [ __ ] beating
because before you sell let's talk
yeah i tell even the guests on the show
come a little early so we can chitchat
smoke a bowl i don't want to throw you
to the [ __ ] lions i want to slow you
down
one of the most genius things i ever
heard was gambino
always had his wife
answer the door
why is that because he wanted her to
slow you down i don't give a [ __ ] if i
just talked to you on the phone and said
lee come right up the stairs come on
talk to me about what troy did to you
he was always in the back room in a
meeting
and as fired up as you were he had her
stop you at the door
sit you down give you a cup of coffee
offer you a cookie yeah
bring a little zenith now you're around
the woman
that could be your mom you know how you
gonna act around your mom
it was a genius move
and that i i didn't think it was a gene
i'm not a gangster but i thought it but
from the other way how you have to slow
your horses down a lot
in life you know when you first come
here you could see the guys that
their nose is wide open not that they're
doing drugs but they want to be a part
of everything you know and they want to
be
i want to be on that show three archer's
gonna be there i gotta be there i gotta
show three hearts how funny i am and
it's kinda and i gotta be honest here i
was part of that you know i was a young
comic i wasn't young i've always been a
dinosaur
but i know what it's like to be in this
town and be overly aggressive yeah you
know a lot of those those roles i got i
got them on my own because i was sending
my own paperwork called the casting
office that's unheard of
that's unheard of but i didn't give a
[ __ ] i'm trying to sell a job i'm trying
to pay the bills troy you said something
very interesting when you had first
started you said you didn't want to do
reality tv
and i know there's a lot of people in la
listening and even new york like when i
first came out here
i was very lucky and very happy to have
had a job but my job was in reality and
it's just so easy to get because that's
all it's a big part of that's all they
have out here and like i've never once
worked on like a scripted show
or anything like that
and that was a movie and that's just so
hard to get that you get in you get in
this little rhythm
of reality shows
and then 20 years later you've edited 20
years but it's all reality shows you
know it's
it's sort of like the nose wide open
thing you should come here and maybe not
take the first job that's offered well
no but you get a good start that way you
know i mean you're going to start
they're all stepping stones yeah those
jobs are all stepping stones to film
and television you know somewhere along
the line some guys in the company go
i just got a show as a producer i need
an assistant
is it reality no it's [ __ ] cbs
it's a show with kevin james and marlo
o'hara whatever the [ __ ] and you're
gonna be my uh producer assistant now
you do that for two years the guy quits
he snorts coke [ __ ] the receptionist
cheats on his wife he quits and guess
who gets the job you do now you're a
[ __ ] producer on the show for three
years maybe it stays on for three or
seven seasons you're a producer for four
years you're making pretty good [ __ ]
money you're doing two seasons a year
and now people calling you going you
want to produce my [ __ ] show on nbc
bam you went from reality to [ __ ]
producer oh it's crazy like that's how
[ __ ] crazy this world is right as
soon as like i finished like i was about
to make the move
to just doing this full time i i
literally i went and i went to the
meeting at the editors union because i
had amassed enough hours
and for my staff for my position which
wasn't great it's an assistant editor i
was gonna make two grand a week
on a union tv show
when and then with because the union i
would have gotten like health benefits
and yeah like maybe i wouldn't be that
thrilled with working in reality but two
thousand a week are you serious i was
like three years out of college i was
like oh [ __ ] yeah
why didn't you pursue it you didn't want
to go forward that was right when i
decided to do this full-time and it was
just
i didn't
it just you were just talking about
levels it's stepping stones it's kind of
hard to get a union a gig because
they're so well paying
but
i was just i didn't want to
like we we i just spent you we we talked
a lot about how i was so [ __ ] [ __ ]
tired i was working 10 to 12 hour days
editing and then coming here
so
and that's it wasn't
my issue was never really
my like morality or like my artistic
sense because like i didn't i wasn't
really in it for like art i was
just doing it
but i just myself wasn't happy
yeah so that's i guess i guess like two
sides of the same coin but right but
within that world like let's say you're
editing in reality television within
that world you can still do something
that matters you can still do something
that's that's a little bit outside the
ordinary and make yourself like doing
something great for you that's what it's
about not i don't mean an artistic sense
i mean like just something that makes
you happy that's like maybe contributes
in a way to that show that the producers
go oh that's [ __ ] amazing we didn't
even think of it this way that's a
really great editor like editors control
everything editors are the ones who make
the movies
make the shows oh yeah and then i'm not
i'm not trying to bash on people in that
industry that's some of the smartest
people like my first boss ever vindabona
essentially created youtube he created
america's funniest on videos in 1988
there's something like 20 this is
probably 26 or 27 seasons
they have shows
all over the world
he's a genius i'm just saying for me i
wasn't happy yeah working in reality
and
this has been
i mean what's better than than doing
this oh my god oh my god you guys this
show what this show does for people it's
amazing how much it affects people you
you just look at the comments that
people make and the way it changes you
how many emails you guys get that tell
people like this is this is [ __ ]
incredible changed my life you know
well you know i thought i always thought
the truth
uh
helps people
i always knew that i had this
truth that i hadn't said to anybody
just talking about what happened in your
life and somebody hearing it
that that happened to you know
they giggle they go jesus christ i don't
feel that bad it's just not me anymore
you know it's uh
it's just so weird how this podcast has
grown and
the people that contact me and the
different emails i get and yeah
you know today i answered 30 emails wow
and the email is usually about
the core of the show which is
being scared and still going for it
because being scared and not going for
it you're not going to get nowhere in
your [ __ ] life
uh
with the drugs how that affected us you
know you and i we were all talking about
drugs for 20 minutes in the beginning of
the show
which was really interesting
conversation about how
drugs evolve in your life
and i didn't i didn't know about that
until cocaine like how
after seven years the drug goes from
being a social drug
to probably like my seventh year it
became a uh
antisocial drug which just instead of
having 15 people in the room
i got it down to maybe three
and by 1994 i had it down to nobody
and i would have a party by myself and
get drunk and talk into the mirror like
denzel and man
fire around and act like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
wave
on
and
uh
i saw the evolution of it i saw how it
made me anti-social i'm usually a person
that likes at least talking [ __ ] with
somebody in an apartment doing some coke
whether it's a
three males or whatever the [ __ ] you
know
but i saw how that and i'm seeing it now
with weed
how sometimes it kicks off
it used to be the edibles when i went to
jiu jitsu
and i stopped all that and sometimes
edibles when you take that extra step
the extra 200 milligrams for us like in
san jose that time that was five
hundred milligrams
and i ate three quarters of that now
and i'll never forget that my body
started changing right there
and i had to ask the manager i go go in
the kitchen and just take a plate or
something
i go because i'm gonna [ __ ] it's
gonna go i gotta eat something to stop
this animal from growing
wow
but now i'm starting to get anxiety i
was telling you that
last saturday i had anxiety
i had to follow nope you know just one
of the regular guys at the store yeah it
wasn't like i had a father [ __ ] lady
murphy or
richard pryor
and i got this dose of anxiety i had a
father the worst was megan mooney that
night that was the [ __ ] worst
morgan murphy morgan murphy that was the
worst
where i was sitting in mitzi's chair
[ __ ] dying
you know
it was just terrible it happened does it
once you get on stage is it still with
you or it's gone no it's gone yeah
that's it i look at the anxiety before i
go on stage
as fear yeah and fear is healthy yeah
yeah it's always fear is healthy it's
healthy to feel free to really think so
very healthy especially when you're in
that
any you're putting yourself in there
you're in any position when you go
cross-training i'll look at leo lee
today we're going to do 400 pounds you
know throw it up in the air run under it
10 times then catch you don't look at me
go joey are you [ __ ] kidding me
i got to take that fear from you and
that's what happened to me with jiu
jitsu like i was really scared like
sometimes when i just tap hands with you
my anxiety level goes up and after i let
you throw me down and stuff
and i tap then i get momentum again i'm
not gonna die i don't know what i'm
anxiety about now i start putting up
resistance now
that first
thing that first hyperventilation
for me is always bad
god forbid i gotta put put [ __ ] uh
stars in me or something like if i have
three stars of me in the morning
and i go to a radio station and then
like you gotta walk up steps
i can't walk up those [ __ ] steps like
listen i don't want to see those stairs
when i'm on animals i don't want to see
no [ __ ] stairs sometimes i take them
early before the airport oh my god
that american airlines you got to walk
to that [ __ ] terminal or southwest
you're huffing and puffing
i get [ __ ] anxiety just just
sometimes when i grasp for and i can't
get it i get anxiety that's why i got
the nose surgery and
all that [ __ ] but
back to stand up
i think that
the anxiety is healthy it's fear those
butterflies yeah that's what it's all
about i know that when i feel those and
and then i have the choice to go or not
go like just say oh no i got these
butterflies maybe let's get the [ __ ] out
of here
when i go through with it it's always
amazing because it's like i've maybe
overcome some hurdle like that fear
looking in the face
and
just diving the [ __ ] in the pool
it's like that did something for me
just that alone you know
when i'm not nervous okay whatever you
know
but that like that anxiety those
butterflies like just go don't don't do
this go
that's that's when the good [ __ ] happens
because like you you just put yourself
in that arena and there's arrows coming
at you and you're swatting them off like
david you know whatever the guy in kung
fu no what is karaoke david kerry now
what is
the uh
definition of fear like
the fear before i go on stage
resistance
the fear of
okay like something came to my mind one
time i was trying to break into his
bookies house and he had a [ __ ] dog
and all week i fed the [ __ ] dog i
didn't think he was gonna turn on me the
night of the robbery he turned on me the
dog and he chased me and not only the
dog chased me cops with flashlights were
chasing me it was a dark hallway behind
an amp in west new york new jersey i'm
57-58
that fear i think of that fear i had
that day i don't know what i was more
scared of the bookie catching me the
cops catching me or the dog catching me
but i remember when
you know when i [ __ ] ran
after i ran like a half a mile
that fear just disappeared i remember
laughing my [ __ ] ass off running like
running looking for cop cars and i
couldn't stop [ __ ] laughing i loved
breaking into apartments
for the thrill of it
not like not like uh
like if somebody said lee has coke
in that office that's where they weigh
the coke and stuff
they have a safe are the only [ __ ]
safes i just picked up and walked out
with
are you [ __ ] kidding me do you know
any [ __ ] safes in my day
i just picked up wait people don't nail
down saves no here's the thing lee i
never knew about this [ __ ] okay i never
knew nothing about safes i was never a
safe cracker
if i walked in the house and there was a
safe i felt like shooting myself
because i knew nothing about saves and
then i when i was about 20 when i was
before i went to colorado at my friend's
house there was this dude that was like
a westie one of the irish mob guys and i
used to always talk to him he had
brothers he had daughters and kids and i
talked to him
and one day he was talking to me about
[ __ ] um
getting a job at this place
for him
as a case he goes you're not a case of
joint because he knew i was a burglar he
knew i was a thief and he goes you know
the case joint's pretty good he was you
want to case him for me because you're
not going to get in trouble we get your
job in there you go to work there for
three weeks write everything down
and then uh we go in there and i'm
telling them there's a safe and he goes
perfect
look to see if it's bolted down and i
said to him so let me ask you something
if there's a save you guys take it he
goes
i could get anything open just not there
we don't have the time to do it there he
goes i got a friend that has a body shop
and they get it open over there
they'll [ __ ] burn that [ __ ] door
down
so i learned from him that he would take
saves
that in 83 i burglarized on christmas
eve i burglarized the family mall at the
snowmass village [ __ ] resort up there
christmas eve christmas day if you woke
up in aspen that said
snowmass village more burglarized
christmas eve it was me on a drunk rage
in those days i used to drink uh
southern comfort no no no i was done
with southern comfort there was
something else creepy i was drinking i
was drinking like a lot of sneaky like
something like that with orange juice
and i would get three of them in me and
i'd go back to thiefen i felt like thief
and i would get drunk to become a thief
and i would i remember one night i was
like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
and i first went and broke into this one
place and took like 800 out of there and
i kicked this other door down and took
like
i picked up the cash register and took
that home then i went back up there and
i broke into this i mean this place was
you know those malls they have
everything towels goggles suntan lotion
it's ski season now so they had [ __ ]
uh hats goggles gloves scarves
you know [ __ ] like that
and uh
i the door it was one of those doors
where all you had to do is put your two
hands on it it's 1983 guys what i do is
put your hands on it and pull
i just broke the bolt with my bare hands
like i just went bop
it opened up i closed it and i took a
walk to see if the alarm went off for
silent alarm i waited 20 minutes no
silent alarm i walked back
i [ __ ] ran in there all the
registered had that regular [ __ ] in
there ten dollars in singles so you took
a walk outside of the mall after you
opened the door wow jesus christ that's
because i wanted to see if the cops were
coming i could see the cops coming at me
like narcos i had a lookout i was a
lookout i could always see because cops
won't put the siren on but to always put
the lights on
yeah so i would look for the [ __ ]
lights lee and if i saw the lights
i get the [ __ ] out of there you know i
knew that place that i could run around
this building and through this building
there was no cameras in those days
you know now you can't do that the
[ __ ] satellite picture
all you need is 72 hours and they'll get
a satellite that was in that area to
photograph that thing and you're dead
you're dead
yeah
so i went back in there i went they had
like three registers where people could
check out you know postcards and [ __ ]
you know ten singles
a roll of nickels
and i went to the back i kicked the
[ __ ] door down in my drunk and there
it was
the [ __ ] safe was right there one of
those skinny saves with the combination
of the top
how much does that thing weigh
whatever
it didn't [ __ ] matter [ __ ] i went
like no hand truck i took a hand truck
there was a little hand truck in the
back i took that [ __ ] hand truck
and i wheeled that savage home and i put
in my buddy's jeep
and the next day we then went to
glenwood springs and we cracked that
[ __ ] open i hit it up like 20
times with a sledgehammer that didn't do
nothing
you have no idea i lost 18 pounds
i robbed another safe one time i robbed
a safe in guttenberg new jersey at the
galaxy towers i was working as a
maintenance [ __ ] man there i would
write the orders for people so i'd have
to deliver the spots to the apartments
no bonded no background check
they just gave me a place to go
that you could take keys off the wall
and they would have three or four keys
on each loop so i just took a key for
each [ __ ] apartment i had to keep the
whole [ __ ] building in the galaxy
they got three towers
this is back in
84
and i would [ __ ] go drop off the
material in people's apartment hello mr
sayad and i would just have you here and
i would keep going back then whatever i
could take
i was crazy guys i was [ __ ] crazy and
i went to this room one time there was
another safe
so i kept the key i took it off the loop
and i i
realized that the people went on
vacation
they were like in europe or something
like that
so friday night i got [ __ ] up with my
friends i told them to wait downstairs i
just walked up like i owned the building
though
took the safe carrier downstairs like a
[ __ ] uh
put like a blanket on top of it yeah
like you were like you were just running
a delivery like you're the guy that does
it one person saw me i put it in the car
and again i had to take it to [ __ ]
c-caucus and light it on fire and that
had like a string of pearls and i got
like the small 2000 oh my god
and then the biggest one that's known as
me and josh wolfe
that time he'll tell you that was the
heaviest safe ever he'll tell you that
adrenaline that that criminal adrenaline
that you get that's a complete different
adrenaline there's sports adrenaline
there's comedy adrenaline
then there's criminal adrenaline and
that shit's crazy that's what makes
somebody stab you 80 times
you know it's hunger it's desire you
want to [ __ ] be a big shot you know
and he said there was going to be 50
grand in there from the boston red sox
yankees seattle mariner series yankees
mariners this is back in 97
eight
he's like yeah there's gonna be [ __ ]
30 grand cash from all the people who
buy beers at the bar
he was going to be out of town so we got
this other guy i got this other guy
listen i got to look outside
do you know when he was parked outside a
cop pulled next to him
like just to pull next to him like to
get coffee
and there's this guy waiting i'll never
forget this i looked out and i saw him
next to the cop and i thought we were
dead
and something made me wait five minutes
and the cop pulled away
and then he pulled the car in front of
the back door and i carried the safe
that's safe
had a at that time way i don't know
and i [ __ ] didn't pick it up i just
pulled it and rolled it on the carpet
you could see the floor going
then there were stairs i just threw it
down the [ __ ] stuff
and it just busted the stairs and i
jumped after it i grabbed it and then
there was another set of concrete stairs
i [ __ ] take that and i [ __ ] carry
it to the door i'm sweating my hands are
cut i'm bleeding you know my heart's
pumping i'm drenched in sweat you're
drenched in that criminal adrenaline
that [ __ ] makes you [ __ ] sweat
everywhere i pulled that [ __ ]
out frankie the whatever his name was
pulled up we popped his trunk we both
[ __ ] we couldn't pick i mean it was
horrific
we picked it up to the bumper
we got to get out of here the cops are
going to go we just flipped it in the
[ __ ] car sank it was like a low rider
we [ __ ] took it over the bridge took
it to where i lived there we [ __ ]
cracked it cracked it cracked it i go to
open the [ __ ] thing and there's a bag
filled with change
six hundred dollars
oh
now we had to take the [ __ ] safe and
dump it
wipe the fingerprints chlorine in the
river oh [ __ ] so he dumped in the
[ __ ] river it's done holy [ __ ] you
just threw it down like no one came out
was like hey everything okay it's sunday
night one in the morning it still sounds
like it look like a bomb it was a it was
a business building
oh my god you have no [ __ ] idea you
have no [ __ ] like doesn't that level
of adrenaline make you feel alive though
like oh you like everything i was
addicted to it yeah i was addicted to it
yeah i was a professional piece of [ __ ]
i was addicted
to it i could put a suit on and go into
a building in case a [ __ ] building i
just opened this door
louie
no no there's no louie in here i knew
there was no louie in here i just came
in here to see what was in here and what
was in here and what were you guys doing
in here
that's why you always close your door
because this guy's like me just knock
and go like this and go louie i got to
be oh [ __ ] i got the wrong office
and you're like thanks for i ain't sorry
about that that guy's case in your world
or you have to assume he's casing your
world
because that's how i cased your office
just a regular fat [ __ ] with a suit on
and you're happy what a nice guy oh my
god he's a gentleman
we love his new jersey accent he's
coming back in and out he's sitting at
the end of the hall waiting for you to
go get hot dogs and feeder go pee and
he's gonna come in here because he's
seen that wallet with your car keys you
put up there that's how fast i can work
wow
it was [ __ ] lightning
it's crazy but i was addicted to that
yeah
[ __ ]
i got addicted
to that that makes sense i got addicted
to it once a week
you know because i was doing at least
one drug burglary a week because you you
rob somebody you do the drugs you hide
for a day you spend the money
and now you need another [ __ ] hookup
don't you think this is exactly like
like you know donald cerrone he's the
way he trains he's out there he's doing
bungee jumping he's skydiving he's a lot
[ __ ] he's doing the same exact thing
that you're talking about like that's
his that's his no it is it's the exact
same thing you're chasing
it's just different [ __ ] performance
different forms of doing it but it's
still the same exact thing and that's
what keeps him alive that's what makes
him passionate about what he does it's
still he's got that adrenaline and he'll
be the first to say like that's my
addiction like i'm i'm never giving that
up and he
it's very clear he's no one's gonna like
dana white comes and says hey we need
you to tone that down he's no i won't do
that that's what i that's what i live
for like that's why i like things that
are real yeah i tell you what brought me
back to life jiu jitsu yeah i was
telling somebody today that it was
because i seen all the weaknesses not
only in my jiu jitsu and my
i saw all the weaknesses in my athletic
abilities i saw the weaknesses in my
personal life how it affected my i saw
the weakness and i couldn't breathe i
was getting anxiety over a guy on top of
me
what happens if two guys come out of a
car and get on top of me they rape my
daughter i can't have that position i
can never be in that situation
so actually you prepare your mind god
knows it's never gonna happen but you
gotta assume it is in today's [ __ ]
big bad world you don't know what the
[ __ ] gonna happen so when i saw all
that hole all those holes in my personal
game i go
i'm going to stick this out but what i'm
addicted to the most is the in the
moment
and i love
my heart beating i love one of my
favorite scenes in any movie because the
director or whoever thought about it was
so brilliant was
godfather before michael shoots the two
guys in the restaurant
the train is stopping you hear train
screeching he
hear him stopping to pick people up
if you've ever done anything
bad in your life
there's a point of the adrenaline that
your ears start ringing
you have no [ __ ] idea when your ears
start ringing when you when you're doing
something and you're deaf from the
adrenaline
that's a complete different world
when i rob that jewelry store with
marblehead that time when i was running
up the corner
i was looking at grand larceny you know
i'm looking at theft i'm looking at a
thousand things i'm looking basically at
twelve and a half [ __ ] years
or maybe eight years with good behavior
but i'm looking at time
my ears were ringing when i was running
once i got around that corner and those
chains were all over the floor and stuff
and i was picking them up
i was the king of the world
that adrenaline fear should have made me
get in that car and drive away but i was
still till today when i asked that
[ __ ] [ __ ] where's the jewelry and he
goes it fell
and like are you [ __ ] kidding me and
you just walked up here with this
and i went and picked up those chains by
this point everybody was out on the
street going hey stop those kids
listen
a bullet wasn't gonna stop me right
there
nothing was gonna i picked up those gold
chains from the back of the car got in
that back seat and we took the [ __ ] off
we hit a right we hit 68th street
whatever the [ __ ] it was
oh
and all of a sudden i light the trunk
because we were going to put the jewelry
in the trunk
but the trunk didn't open
the trunk was jammed so we had to put in
the back seat the beauty of this is at
the first light we stopped as a cop
and the trunk opens up as the cop is
passing by
the cop never noticed it and we [ __ ]
got the jewelry off but that fear i had
running around that [ __ ] hill
when i uh
when i got in trouble in boulder and i
kidnapped vela
while vela was in the apartment when
those him and the biker were there that
tidwell [ __ ] were arguing and i left
him there when i walked into that house
that was the best adrenaline i ever had
in my life wow
because there was a
a guy that opened the door for you a
door guy dressed in an outfit in front
of this building
now i had just been there an hour before
to pick the victim up and to take him to
the location
when my friend went over he stopped him
whatever
and they buzzed him up i don't know how
he got up but when i went back
from the way i slammed that door
when he saw i'll never forget the look
on his face
my body language the adrenaline was
coming out of my [ __ ] ears
because he didn't say good afternoon he
even opened the door for me i just
walked in that [ __ ] building
i got in the elevator and i went
upstairs and i basically
walked to the door and kicked it in
my ears were on fire
i mean my body was just hot hot that's
that's a [ __ ] great feeling when
you're on [ __ ] fire and i kicked the
door in
and they had like a ceiling and i just
jumped up and pulled it down
i pulled the whole [ __ ] you know
those uh
dropped tile drop tiles yes like the
coke wasn't one of those tiles i knew
the tile guess what i didn't have time i
just jumped up like a gorilla that i am
oh my gosh and pulled it uh and the
thing just came ah it was like it looked
like 9 11. you ever see all those things
hanging that's how the roof looks oh my
god
like the basement of tower 4 whatever
the [ __ ] it was there was beams hanging
dust everywhere when i walked out i had
dust all over my face my shirt
i had ripped that [ __ ] ceiling down i
[ __ ] picked up that coke and i went
in the car you have no idea how i felt
by the time i got out i was already that
clear because it's so funny how you
feeling dog i'm feeling ready for
another stop sure but i'm just like how
how did you only get caught
down buildings you're kicking down doors
you're doing 911. you're a you're
you're
you're a [ __ ] you're adrenaline yeah
will take you to places you can't think
you can't think logically but here's the
beauty of it that i've always thought
about okay so i parked the car facing
whatever the [ __ ] this direction
but when i got the car
to my right but when i got in the car
i noticed that there was a newspaper
thing and already my head was clear
because when i pulled out of that thing
i crossed over right onto 19th and
canyon boulevard and that's where the
halfway house is
how [ __ ] how much of a sign is that
and i went in i ripped apart the two
kilos
and i took and i took like a [ __ ]
handful of coca and put it in like a
newspaper that i had in the car that's
how much of a primitive guy it was i
took the two [ __ ] packages and i put
them under the newspaper thing
so i wouldn't have them on me
you follow
one of those newspaper dispensers or
whatever it's called in the street yeah
not done at the spencer but those little
yeah those little stands you get your uh
yeah
your free paper
wrap it another quarter paper yeah under
there because i didn't want it on me if
the cops pulled me over
and that [ __ ] guy at the door didn't
even look at me
on the way out didn't say thank you for
coming thank you for shopping here
nothing
[ __ ] not zero respect roy conrad jesus
now well you you you do something like
that with that level of adrenaline you
go home how how long before you can
sleep because that [ __ ] stays
they call it adrenaline dump is that
what it's called yeah yeah when it's
when it's you get it all out and then it
just brings you down but but coke would
bring you right back
so yeah the adrenaline dump is when you
get it all out it's just like oh and
then and then you get home and it starts
to wear off and it's like really goes
really low
right
and that's when the soreness comes in
yeah that's when you realize [ __ ] i
dropped the glove in front of caleb
because he damn you don't notice the
glove when there's adrenaline that's why
that happened yeah that's why
the knife slips yeah it cuts your
fingers yep you know when i was running
from the cops and that dog i ripped my
hand open i got caught on the barbed
wire i had to untake the glove from my
skin no no no that bean guy you have no
idea in today's modern world i would
have passed out but the adrenaline
right
kept me going kept me going i didn't
even think of my hand bleeding no
fainting no fainting no fainting in fact
i went home and left the glove on i said
why [ __ ] with it let me go to the ball
with the glove on the glove was filled
with blood oh jesus
i would squeeze it and blood would come
out of the glove and [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
i never drink though
[ __ ] it couple cocktails couple valiums
i went home like a soldier the next day
i went to the hospital because i knew
they couldn't stitch me up
because after 12 hours they can't stitch
you up so they could just
so i went 12 hours later they cleaned it
out with the [ __ ] good stuff
oh my god it's an open wound it was just
an open [ __ ] oh my god jesus just
thinking about this [ __ ] that state of
mind i was in those few years
just picture that glove like you're
squeezing and just squirting blood out
oh my god i had a tooth i never went to
the dentist i had a tooth that had an
abscess and had a little ball on the
side and i would go to the comedy store
i'd be talking to somebody and they
you'd be standing if i didn't like it i
could squeeze it and the [ __ ] juice
would come out of the hole
that's some christine buzzinski's like
[ __ ] right there jack
what does she is that she was at the
store last night she looked beautiful
yeah she was great she looked [ __ ]
beautiful her and tom are doing great
they got the baby
the baby's a [ __ ] gorilla they don't
know what to do with them
he's eating a [ __ ] regular
cheesesteak from new jersey sam's
whatever the [ __ ] that is
no all that stuff uh
now would you black out when you said
when you said you you don't you can't
think were you blacking out or were you
conscious of what you were doing
or would you just come to in the car
like oh [ __ ]
50 50. then i would laugh my ass off
like i'm about to do right now
like i did this scary thing one time i
did was scary scary like even looking
back today
i uh
had a friend and uh
things went south
she got pissed for some reason or
another i got pissed at her
you know she was a drug dealer you know
she was a big time medium level
drug dealer
i had met her through friends you know
and i had known her for a few years and
the weird thing was as good as i knew
her every time i go over there
she'd always take your money
or ask you what you want and she'd go in
the back room
and then bring you the goat and then you
give her the money she'd weigh it in the
back room
she'd ask you to look at it she was very
cool and see if you like it you know if
you want more rock or whatever she was
probably she gave you a great coke
you know
uh
i went over there one night the cop
she was no miss america
you know what i'm saying and uh
everybody knew that and at the time i
thought i was cute and i went over and
tried to be cute with her
and she rejected it and i got pissed off
you know like a young man would do like
an [ __ ] that would do
and i never messed with her again until
one day i needed money and i go you know
what that's the house we're gonna
[ __ ] rob
i knew the
consequences first off
at that time
i knew that they were going to point all
the fingers at me
i knew that this was going to come back
to me at one point or another
but at that point in my life i really
didn't give a [ __ ] because i expected
her to have a tremendous load in that
house
we were going to [ __ ] become
millionaires in my mind i was always
going to become a [ __ ] millionaire
and my demented drug addicted
young mind
they had a million dollars stashed and
that was it i was gonna buy a [ __ ]
supra
you know you're a [ __ ] kid you know
you got the dumbest [ __ ] ideas
and one day i put a crew together i got
my butt two of my buddies i said listen
man there's a [ __ ] big payoff there
and when i told them the name both of
them looked at me like you don't want to
do that i go yes we are
that's why we're doing it because they
don't expect nobody to get hit
you know what i'm saying they don't
expect nobody to get hit now i thought i
had the door when i got there i couldn't
get the door
i was always good with doors
and i would look at them and try to come
up with a way where i could get into
that door quick
she was a drug dealer but she didn't
have a top bolt
what kind of [ __ ] dummy are you it's
that easy to get in without a top bowl
well it's only one instead of two yeah
and it's white you know those little
regular things i could
you could go through you could put a
shoulder into those [ __ ] things a
good shoulder hit it close to the door
like don't go in the middle of the
[ __ ] door if you're trying to break
that you're trying to break that right
there that grip yeah it's like when you
break a grip you push away from the
fingers same [ __ ] thing you got to
push away p in the movies they always go
to the door like johnny bananas no
i would treat it like a football tackle
and i would get like a three-point
stance
and that's why my shoulders probably
jacked today and i would put everything
i had into that middle and then i would
have a gorilla going behind me
and we'd wipe the [ __ ] door open
or i'd bring a screwdriver i could say
get a screwdriver in there there was
always different angles maybe there was
a glass on your door i could break the
glass and put my arm through and open up
the [ __ ] door there's always an angle
the consumer doesn't know it
yeah i know it where i just moved into
this glass the door i don't like it
that's getting covered up this week
because i don't like glass in the front
that's just a no [ __ ] brain
whether it's your ball somebody over
here really
really somebody will [ __ ] hear it
nobody will hear it
nobody hears [ __ ] we're programmed not
to hit deck and if they do who's going
to go outside just like what are you
guessing what the [ __ ]
yeah i'll break the glass and walk away
so they come out they don't really see
nothing they get back in the house
there's so many things people don't see
that you think people are gonna see they
don't see
i've done a thousand things right in
front of people looking at me and they
don't see it
your mind doesn't pick it up something
i've seen it a thousand times you're not
looking for that you're not looking for
a drug deal going down on your street so
you're sitting in front of your drink
with your husband drinking coffee
and i come up with like a [ __ ] uh
construction bag or a gym bag but i'm
dressed like a gym guy
you're following me you come up looking
the way you are and i sold you an ounce
of coke right there
and you got on the bus i made you get on
the bus get off the next block walk back
two blocks what's the big [ __ ] deal
plus how often when you're driving well
you just look up and be like oh i don't
remember the last five minutes of this
i think that happens in everyday life i
don't think it just happens when you're
driving especially if you're doing
something that you do a lot like your
morning coffee
or or mowing the lawn you just
phase out and you're not you're making
it very easy for people to not notice it
because you're acting like you're
supposed to be there wherever you are
like that's that's the skill right
that's it when you're wheeling it when
you're taking a hand truck with a save
you put a blanket on it you see somebody
hey how are you doing you wavered out
yeah i love you
you want to get the uh this thing's
really heavy you want to help me put
this on oh my god it happened
absolutely last night uh pablo escobar
he goes into the store and the cop drops
a corner and he gives the corner to the
[ __ ] cop
the most wanted [ __ ] man that happens
every [ __ ] day
i used to i used to do this i'd sneak
into concerts but my thing was uh i
would walk right in the front door and
then like one of the times there was
like three bouncers and i just walked
down go hey guys
what uh we're getting pizzas what do you
want and i go oh we're gonna go
pepperoni we'll do two what do you want
all right all right guys all right and i
and i just walk in but like i act like
i'm supposed to like why would anyone
walk in getting pizzas for the bouncers
you know that made me a posit in a
position of authority and i could just
walk right in enjoy the show it's
amazing what you could do with body
language oh yeah if you if you act like
you are supposed to be there nobody
really questions that it's
amazing yeah how much body language
contributes
to so much when you watch those shows
and discovery like i don't watch a lot
of shows and discovery but this time i'm
in a hotel room i just did two [ __ ]
shows 250 people a show i talked to 200
people i go back to my hotel room you're
not you're tired but you're so tired
your body's glowing
so what do you put on that that show you
like the prison show or my 600 pound
life that's the [ __ ] you watch late at
night because it don't need a lot of
attention to watch
and it calms you down that stupid [ __ ]
you're not gonna get into seven
at two in the morning because that'll
take you till six
you follow me seven movies like that
scarface oh yeah you know something
comes on at that at that time one third
you're doomed but
the cops show about what happens it's
cell gate c and all that [ __ ] you'll
stay a [ __ ] way for you
you'll wake up and it's still on them
they're still in some [ __ ] jail in
new mexico smacking people in the head
with sticks and [ __ ]
it's funny
it's weird
i uh i said we talked last week how i
was gonna get rid of the facebook app i
did that
i i got rid of cable
and and it's weird how
all these like those kind of shows
can take over your life i like i had
i had the uh
one of my first big screen tvs
i had burned into
the espn side thing that on sportscenter
where it tells you what the topics are
going to be because i would just leave
it on all night oh [ __ ]
and like
when you take that stuff away that you
get addicted to it's amazing how much
more time there is
like it's weird it'll change your life
yeah i took the facebook app off my
phone oh it's four or four or five years
ago and it's it's amazing how nice it is
to not have alerts all the time over
things that are not important for your
life it actually lets you live
yeah
i uh
moved this weekend
and there was times that i would put you
know hotmail on i was like we were
talking we get stoned
and we open up all five links and you
open up wikipedia and you're researching
you're looking for plane tickets and
you're sending an email
and you're waiting for somebody to send
you an address on twitter
so you go back and forth to twitter
and there are days where i don't write
on twitter on the weekends
you know i made myself a personal thing
sunday at five
i'm allowed to [ __ ] around on twitter
before that i'm not allowed to [ __ ]
around on twitter
you got to give yourself a day and a
half two days friday people are
traveling
we said well we had to say monday
tuesday wednesday and thursday people
don't comprehend that yeah don't get on
twitter and go where you've been blah
blah
you have to give this
thing a [ __ ] breather yeah you know
people always go to me joey you have so
many [ __ ] stories because i didn't
have a [ __ ] internet
yeah you know you're reading about these
stupid [ __ ] stories because you're
sitting there reading it's two in the
[ __ ] afternoon why are you in the
goddamn house
why the [ __ ] are you in the goddamn
house
i could see of your hurricane camilo
whatever the [ __ ] his name is that's in
new jersey now it's [ __ ] raining
but i never understood uh
that part of it you know if you want you
have to cut the [ __ ] that
takes time away from you the worst thing
is uh is
getting yourself in a position where
you're just staying at home uh and doing
stuff from home because
that just that just can lead you there's
no you're not accountable to anybody and
it's you can just do whatever the [ __ ]
you want and it and you don't do the
important stuff you end up doing the
[ __ ] stuff when the first that when
i first moved to uh los angeles i rented
a room from a writer
and uh the deal was he said you can only
uh you only get to sleep here
so this room is yours from you know ten
o'clock at night until nine in the
morning you gotta be gone at nine
but you can live here
so this guy because he used he was a
writer and he used the place during the
day and he had meetings there so i had
to be out
and and
i just ended up finding great i that
that was i got so much stuff done i met
so many people i was out there in the
world i was out there in hollywood a
town new to me that was the best thing i
ever did if i was at home just on the
internet i would have been living this
virtual life like who knows what the
[ __ ] you know
but that was great to just be propelled
out there
when i was 18 when i was going through
high school hbo was still pretty new
and hbo had a show about a guy who
hitchhiked the hitchhiker
how's it going i think that's what it
was called there was a guy who got in
cars and sometimes women bloom
and sometimes you just got to meet
people and go to a different town
it was sort of like kung fu
he kept traveling you know
that was always like a distant dream for
me but after my mother died i had no
hooks in new jersey
so that gave me the green light to
experiment a little bit and travel you
know
i looked around a lot when i was growing
up and i looked what these guys were
doing and some of them were successful
in their own little way considering they
where they were coming from you know
coming from my same neighborhood very
blue collar and now they got into some
managerial union position and maybe
they're making 90k a year
and that entitles them to pay their
mortgage and have his wife a nice car
you know [ __ ] like that you know
but i would see their traveling patterns
and then we'll go to atlantic city and
they will go to florida
and this is what they did every year
they wouldn't even [ __ ] consider
going past chicago
and i always thought there was a little
bit more to life
you know
so when i got the opportunity to travel
you know i was always intrigued with
colorado
because when i was a kid on abc news
when you were watching eyewitness news
that i was put you know even today
uh 10 o'clock eastern seven o'clock
pacific nine o'clock western at eight
o'clock mountain time
and i always said mountain time how
[ __ ] up is mountain time where the
[ __ ] is mountain
so when i got to go to colorado it was
because of mountain time i liked the
idea
when i moved to seattle is because i
liked the seattle supersonics for a
while they were in the finals one year
with jack sigma that's why you moved
there yeah it was just but i liked the
logo to the comedy club
the seattle underground i just thought
there was something to it you know there
was something to it all those names
meant a lot to me when i first got into
comedy it meant a lot to me to play that
club in boston
uh in the [ __ ] market there that you
that closed down lee what was the name
of that place oh uh kelsey hall
nathaniel faneuil hall
there were all these locations that you
had to play in because they were your
goals
you know this was part of your goals you
had to play the comedy store
and the underground and you had to play
uh what was in phoenix when i started
interesting that you started in phoenix
yeah so phoenix had with knuckleheads he
had the comedy uh comedy zone six clubs
in 94 or something like that yeah yeah
absolutely you started with stanhope
stanhope started in phoenix yeah yeah we
had yeah we we the first uh the first
paid gig i ever had was with stand up
standard was i think he was featured he
was featuring at that point uh he was
featured in improv he was the god of
that time like you're featuring the
improv like uh and it was ge howard's
club it was called uh
uh i want to say it was well it used to
be finney bones and then it became like
comedy zone or something like that it
wasn't one of those hotel
you know restaurant bar things right
[ __ ] like crazy you know what i'm
talking about because if anybody was
finney bones in a comedy zone i think
but it was crazy man there was so many
clubs at that time and then i forgot the
laughs the one on the freeway was like
laughs
not less unlimited but something like
that it was laughs and
tucson was last then there was the last
in new mexico yeah in albuquerque
before ross rivas
it was a guy's club that died in the
motorcycle accident on new year's day
a great [ __ ] guy just a great because
that was the thing laps had a bad name
except his club
he was a mexican dude he was a biker
you when he took you to dinners he
treated you good he put you in a hotel
where uh
the other two clubs laughs and the other
one in tucson
were kind of [ __ ] shitholes so
he would not i don't i'm just saying
this at the time guys the worst condos
he died
and rush i started with russ wow it's so
weird i was a doorman and russ was
already featuring
oh [ __ ] all right at the wit's end and
and then oh yeah yeah oh that's right i
forgot you did what's it that was my
favorite club in colorado
and then i told the guy i'm want to do
comedy and he was like you'll never make
it not in this town you're
you're a big new yorker and you trust me
on this stay do what you're doing here
you'll be managing this place and i'm
like [ __ ] you
i'm gonna get on [ __ ] stage what i'm
gonna stay here with you and
give orders to these young kids and your
[ __ ]
and uh the big clubs what what the [ __ ]
were they yeah yeah knuckleheads there
was always an improv in tempe yeah and
then there was that one that opened in
the scottsdale mall it was like the
it was like a then like name like the
sphere or some kind of like technoy name
you know what i'm talking about who's in
this like scottsdale plaza this is what
happened i'm gonna tell you my [ __ ]
experience in this
in the spring
the
spring is march
spring of 95
spring of 94
i get a
a call i talk to a buddy of mine his
name is todd jordan great comic
and we're having a discussion and i go
what's some good clubs that are locally
that you get me a showcase at and he
goes why don't you you could eat one of
those just eat half of it first i don't
want you to pull it on benjamin
next thing you know you're in glendale
talking to armenians eating the shish
kebabs and [ __ ] you don't know what joey
d is you just need a half of it yeah
just to get into your head a little bit
what we talking about hillary
the clubs all those phoenix clubs the
phoenix club so i call this guy he says
to me joey it's time for you to start
going out and showcasing i go what's a
showcase he goes you gotta go to clubs
and do a free set
and let them know you're [ __ ] alive
he goes because nobody's doing that this
is how you get into clubs like all right
fine
so
i called knuckleheads because at the
time knucklehead had three clubs they
had phoenix they had minneapolis and
they had somewhere else
yeah um i don't remember where but they
did like portland
portland minneapolis and uh and phoenix
i go how far is the drive to [ __ ]
phoenix they tell me like 12 hours i say
[ __ ] it there was no thought of a plane
in those days in my world
at that time i worked for the national
car rental
and i was i became friends with this kid
and he was just a great kid
and he really admired what i was doing
he was young if i was
30 he had to be 25.
and he admired what i was doing he was
like really you're going to do stand-up
tonight yeah i'm going to tag along and
then when they came to me goes hey man i
want to help you with your career
i say you're a writer you know people he
goes no
he goes pass out this box of flies and i
give you a hundred bucks
it was an hour to work
every once in a while he called me up
you and then it got to the point where i
would just call him up and borrow
against the work he'd give me
then he got me a job when i went in and
applied he got me the job and then he
became my boss
so i went to him like a man i go hey man
i'm in a [ __ ] bind
is there any way i can rent a car from
you
and you can take it out of my check and
i'll work here for the next three weeks
for free
and he goes what about brand new car and
if you bring it back
the bill will get lost
wait what does that mean
he's going to rip up the bill and
say that he had to take the car for
business oh yeah you got to take the car
to drive somebody
on a certain date
i mean he that broke my heart
like i had to borrow 200 from a friend
of mine lucerillo just to get gas money
that i was going to give to him and then
i was going to borrow another 100 from a
friend of mine joe koch and try to
figure it out this is how crazy i was
like i was going to get in the car with
a hundred dollars and go to phoenix
drive 12 hours with 100 bucks didn't
give a [ __ ] that's how much the dream
meant to me i'll figure out how to come
back
i'll figure it out i'll rob a gas
station i'll figure it the [ __ ] out
i got in that car this kid didn't charge
me so i had 200 hours
and 200 was perfect for the drive down
there and i took the 200 i got in that
[ __ ] car
and you know as hungry as you are i
drove nine hours i pulled over
i slept at some [ __ ] parking lot
until the sun came back out
and then i found the gas station
broke brushed my teeth put water in my
face
and i went to the club and i sat there i
thought the club was open all day in
those days and i could just walk in and
say hey i'm a comedian sure go down to
the corner there's a hotel room they'll
put you in tell them it's us
get a meal at the restaurant and then
come back and do a show that's how i
thought comedy worked
like that's how [ __ ] i was
i go to the club i knock on the door
that [ __ ] is shut tight jack i'm
sitting out there all day in that
[ __ ] sun and that heat in phoenix in
a car with air conditioning i had
nowhere to go i had no friends i didn't
know the [ __ ] the call
nobody had nobody to [ __ ] i don't
know nothing about phoenix i hadn't been
to tempe since 84.
i used to go to tempe and visit a buddy
of mine that was down there on the lamb
he was down there smoking mushrooms with
indians and [ __ ] like that so
i would visit him i knew nobody i sat in
that parking lot lee in that comedy
store parking lot and wrote stupid
[ __ ] jokes and
wrote my dreams down and how i was going
to [ __ ] bust out and somebody was
going to see me somewhere at one of
these clubs and i wouldn't have to do
what every other comic did at first
that's what i thought i really believed
i was just gonna go on stage somebody's
gonna see me and go come on let's go i
think everybody had that starting out no
that was a time well that was a time
where you would hear about like oh yeah
this person gets discovered from the
comedy club and there was a time where
that kind of thing you'd hear about
really but it wasn't a reality it was
just like i think it was one of those
like yeah that's how you get discovered
like people were doing it for that they
were like 90s anyway
i just wanted to be saved i just wanted
to stop being a criminal
and i'm like [ __ ] somebody sees me
it's over
like if somebody could see my
five-minute set
and they could just take me to richard
pryor's house
we could do jokes and [ __ ] like that's
what i really thought that's how stupid
and naive i was
so i waited for them to come
i went inside i asked for whatever the
guy's name was
i mean i got there in the waitresses
will hate me because i was in the way
you know
i had to use that bathroom to get ready
and use a shirt i mean this was ghetto
to the max league you don't know when
somebody walks into your club is there a
bathroom
you know and i'm in there no shirt on
with paper towels wiping my armpits and
my face brushing my teeth
wetting my hair putting gel in my hair
with a shirt that was crinkled up
then i'm sitting at a bar you know after
that i'm sitting at the [ __ ] bar as
annoying as can be
so what time's the show start and then
like is jeffy and jeff i'm i called you
for the guest of mine all right
guys like cool yeah you could do a guest
spot man everybody was cold to me
they charged me for a coke i was furious
then the first show came in
and i got on stage and just my accent
killed them
there were some new yorkers and they
they're laughing and [ __ ] and i was
talking about godzilla i was doing
terrible material
but i took them to where they had to go
for five minutes i get on stage
i go to pay my tab the guy goes no no no
he goes do me a favor can you stay for
the second show
they didn't charge you for drinks ever
again and then he asked me was you
hungry
was i [ __ ] hungry late i was trying
to eat my finger because i didn't know
how much money i needed to but at that
point i probably had 90 bucks that and i
needed 80 for gas so i couldn't take a
chance and even get a veggie that was
only got a veggie and cheese that was
the cheapest thing i could get a subway
veggie and cheese
and he go stay for the second show
i stayed did the second show i think i
ate like a roast beef sandwich i didn't
really want to be too over the top i
didn't drink anything i had no coke
nothing i was and the second show were
late and i think i cursed and i did
better
so he goes wait i'll talk to you in a
second he brought me in the back and he
goes uh when do you want to come back
here and i go i don't care no and he
goes how about you come for two weeks
like eight months from that date
whatever it was april i was gonna come
back like in november
he goes you could stay for two weeks
300 a week maybe 250 a week to emcee
i had to drive down there i didn't give
a [ __ ] lee i was getting my break this
is it
and then uh he goes what are you doing
tonight where are you staying i go in
the car he goes no no no
go to the condo uh the feature is local
go over there and take a shower take a
bath spend the night you could stay till
monday
wow
and i went over there i got up i watched
uh some baseball the other comic i don't
know who the [ __ ] headliner was
i asked him creepy questions that night
and creepy questions that morning he got
me high we went to breakfast he gave me
his number
and i got back in that control back with
two [ __ ] weeks of work at a club as
an emcee i didn't give a [ __ ] like
i was going back to the great [ __ ]
that's the best feeling it was the
[ __ ] best and then i get home and i'm
doing comedy i'm fighting my wife and
all this [ __ ]
i'm getting into the comedy where
someone else i got a
[ __ ] page
it's a voicemail and i get out of there
like hey joey it's joe from knuckleheads
i just want you know we're closing
like what do you mean you're closing you
closing tonight and he goes no we're
closing the whole chain
and that was my first experience with
[ __ ] comedy on the road where's that
tony bennett second
um
look at that we asking for a [ __ ]
bunk when was the last time you asked
for a bong me huh [ __ ] sucker not in a
while i said it's over now
lee i didn't bring you a check huh
sorry about that buddy i'll see you
tomorrow okay
[ __ ] beautiful jam for you
monday september 5th
this is it guys like i was talking about
in the periscope
thank you lee
i was telling these guys on the
periscope the reality is it's september
5th
this is the fourth quarter
that's it
you're at the [ __ ] you're at that
30-yard line you're marching in jack
this is it this goes by
so [ __ ] fast now
that you can't blink an eye if you
haven't gotten your [ __ ] together by
this time of the year it gets ugly
your unemployment runs out about this
time and [ __ ] once the unemployment runs
out in october it's a cold [ __ ]
out there
you gotta take one of those kitchen jobs
and [ __ ] you've always dreaded
cooking and [ __ ] frying [ __ ] and
talking chinese to people
you want another one no were you ready
for a bang of life yet
think i like the guy [ __ ] what's his
name choke the narcos remember how his
eyeballs got ready
they don't [ __ ] around down there
so you started as a comic in phoenix
yeah who else besides stanhope you
remember
oh
god man well i mean this was when you
know there was genesis i don't know if
you ever knew genesis uh then pablo
francisco was in tucson he would come up
and there was ron maury you must know
ron moore
monster i love that man and then gary
menke so those are the guys i started
manky
the manker he just passed away no no not
not manky manky's still running a club i
want to say he's running a improv in
tampa or something like that oh that
gary menke okay yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
who died from
her no no the other guy died too mark
anderson no the guy from uh lapse he was
like he's always been at labs tucson as
an assistant kind of sort of nice
sweetheart no not uh gary hood yeah gary
hood i didn't know gary
i don't think gary was taking care of
himself no he wasn't as a matter of fact
the last time i worked at club uh i want
to
say six years ago uh he was
i stayed at his place and he was
definitely in really bad health like he
was you know he was having a lot of
trouble i think i think he had diabetes
and he i don't know man things were bad
though you know man i'm over 50 and i
got to be honest with you guys once you
hit 50
you could go at any time
that's a [ __ ] reality you're going
any time
no symptoms you know you stretch for
something you get a heart attack you go
to any [ __ ] time my heart has lasted
as long as it did
especially after these adrenaline
stories and the code
and there's 20 more of those adrenaline
stories that can't come to my mind right
now
so you uh
you know people always say to me joey
you should do the third week a month on
the road you should do this you should
i don't want to die on the road
yeah one of my biggest fears is for my
wife to have to call lee and say you
have to go sign for them i can't go i
got the kid
i can't hold a kid and then from there
why even send them back to california
send me straight to north bergen new
jersey so i could die with veneria at
the parlor over there you know what i'm
saying besides giving me half price
that's a [ __ ] savior these days
so you got to work that way once you hit
50 you really got to think that way so
you have to take a little care of
yourself i think the road you could take
care of yourself on the road i'm not
saying you cannot
you could stay away from greasy food
because i do it now
i do it now it costs you a little bit
you have to walk a little bit and do
what you need to do but you go to
galson's you know what i'm saying you
know listen you cannot eat three [ __ ]
meals like an animal like that after the
age of 35. you cannot i can't
yeah i'm talking about waking up and
going to houston let's say i'm in
houston texas waking up and getting uh
a cheese omelet with [ __ ] french
fries crinkle cut fries with a
[ __ ] side order a white toast
with his iced tea with sugar and lemon
in that [ __ ]
yeah but on the way over you gotta get a
couple kalachis and [ __ ] so they get
your blood going then you go home and
take a nap then you wake up and go to
auntie chang's duncan palace and you
have the [ __ ] lunch special plus an
extra [ __ ] order of spare ribs
because you're an animal then you go
home and you eat a [ __ ] sandwich
while you're watching maury or whatever
some chick that's trying to get pregnant
by white people then
then for dinner you go either the
[ __ ] restaurant again yeah and the
fried food you know and then you gotta
get the late night taco bell then you
gotta get the late night it kills you on
the road and people don't i don't get
stressed out on the road listen
i do not get stressed out my stress
levels in fact i have a great time to be
honest with you guys
i think it's a travel
it's the travel that wears me down yeah
i had to take a nap today guys i didn't
do much this week and i had to take a
nap today because my body's programmed
to nap on sundays how long are you doing
that for
what's that how long like how long do
you nap for a day like that an hour and
a
half
when i go on the road and i wake up at
five in the [ __ ] morning
and you get on a plane to come home when
i get home i'm up till about two and
then i'll sleep in two to five we will
not do the podcast on a sunday night
because i'll be tired i don't wanna
i don't want to deal with somebody four
nights in a row that's a lot of nights i
might not go to the store tonight to be
honest
yeah i don't feel too good today i'm
starting to get something i think i'm
just gonna stay on my [ __ ] business
you gotta take care of yourself as a
comic you do you really do you know
there's five nights a week you could get
caught up drinking on all those nights
and
picking at food
and then you sleep late and i ate the
dog i went up to 4 18. you're talking to
the wrong guy
you know you sit at the comedy store at
night you drink those coca-colas
all night long with rum you think that
you know those are 400 calories a piece
no there was no fried chicken at the
store
i have not really ate the fried chicken
one night
yeah not the fried chicken the chicken
tenders the chicken tomatoes yeah there
was no yeah that wasn't the kitchen then
that was just the dishwashing they had
the booze there
and they had that they used to wash the
glasses there and [ __ ] okay well do you
guys like eating late even when you're
home
because like i'm
like i can i will not eat during the day
like i'll have like one meal
but like at 11 o'clock even without the
edibles sometimes mike like i'll just
want to eat
yeah
and that's like apparently the worst
thing for you to do yeah
no i'm not going to sit here and tell
you i never did it
lee and i have a discussion once a week
i bor lee with the same [ __ ] story
about
my dream lead there's only one i love
lee
everyone loves lee uh
lisa fat [ __ ] like me me and lee and me
and lee together are not a good couple
on the other side lee knows it
liam and me when we go out to eat we
[ __ ] throw down
when we immediately go out to eat we'll
[ __ ] your world up chocolate cake
you know and lee's not gonna say no to
me and i'm not going to say no to lee
and i know what lee's thinking when he
looks at the menu i know lee that
[ __ ] well
he's looking at the most i could take
leader [ __ ] hardy morton's
and he'll pick the most disgusting thing
on the menu but i'm proud of him
i'm proud of him i'm gonna go league go
he'll get the potatoes he'll go for he
ate the lobster last time he don't like
lobster he ate the lobster with me
he ate the lobster with me [ __ ]
yeah we got a coupon or something people
sent us like 100
and me and lee went and lee had the
[ __ ] fraud like only i don't like
lobster that night he was [ __ ] either
you you
one quality you have is you are good at
being fat like
i've been thinking about a lot there's
people who are fat and you talk you talk
about by eating good food what you
really mean is that you know what like
not that it's good quality but it just
it's what is the [ __ ] best like paula
will come to me and be like you're me
like my meal is always better than her
meal
because i keep it simple and i just know
because i spent a lot of time being fat
i know what's going to be good
and like can i tell you what i've trust
me i've been to taco bell
i've never once ordered one of those
doritos tacos
about the new thing with the cheese in
the middle that's time okay because i'll
tell you why you can't [ __ ] with here
here you go you can't [ __ ] with taco
bell's cheese because they use the
disgusting cheese sauce that's gross
i'll put that in quesadillas and call
that a quesadilla yeah that's really
sick i would rather i don't want to
throw it in their face when they do that
to me but that like that you can't
totally make it like that
like you you
like know like we go to morton's
you get the steak and you know you
just
you are like i told you a couple weeks
ago you're very calculated and it it
goes to eating too
like you know the salad you know the
thing but you you know like the the your
trick was the chocolate cake because
that's how
no one would order that wait what's the
chocolate cake trick it's like it it's
not a trick it's just like a six layered
amazing chocolate cake with homemade
whipped cream i would never get dessert
we know we never get when i go to no we
don't ever get dessert but this cake
oh my god
i wouldn't make you get nothing unless i
was throwing heat at you
like i'm the type of guy that if i got
the best coke in town i know you don't
do coke i'll call you overlook it i know
you're gonna do coke but do a blast for
this you can tell people you did the
mother of pearl coke this is directing
the chinese palace and [ __ ]
this is mixed with yin yang juice and
acupuncture needles you snort this [ __ ]
it's over
that's the type of guy i am i don't like
[ __ ] around with people
i don't like wasting people's time when
it blows me out of the water it'll blow
a civilian
because it takes a lot to blow my
[ __ ] head off
it's like that spicy lobster at that
place it blows your [ __ ] head off
you could go there and just get eight
appetizer plates of that and me and lee
would mean we'll do that before the year
so
we're going to do one of these podcasts
and today i'm going to leave it in the
car well i got to put the podcast up
people going to complain lee
get in the car i want a two-point entry
i'm trying to tame them terry to do a
two-point
a nightmare it's a [ __ ] nightmare 30
years old he couldn't get a license in
jersey you got to do a two-point [ __ ]
parking
he can't two-point exit this is a swoosh
and you pull out like what i do it every
time now no he doesn't it takes him an
hour
he moves an inch of foot cause you do it
right after the podcast
it's like this i don't want to hit
something you're not gonna hit nothing
i'm right there with my hand
i am right there with my hand and he's
got a [ __ ] camera behind us yeah i
love that you're right there by the way
because that's
you you love that
i don't think you'd be behind like
stepping behind my car and getting hit a
little bit just another thing oh i'm
waiting to get tapped you know me i'll
catch you like i want to wake up i'll
[ __ ] no i just go down that's it
all i need is a car to go like this look
that's it i'm going down
it's over ah
ah what hurts everything
don't be specific jew training 101.
everything even you got to think about
the attorney at court what's he's going
to ask you at the moment you got hit
with the car mr diaz
what hurt
you yelled and
what i said everything what am i [ __ ]
[ __ ] i just told you
the [ __ ] what the ambulance guy said
everything hurt
when you said everything you mean
everything like what your knee your leg
listen to me
i could feel my fungi toe vibrating you
know he almost knocked the nail off my
fungi nail and he knocked the liquid out
of my ear i can't even hear you right
now i don't even know what the [ __ ] i'm
here if it wasn't for the sign language
guy behind you
that's the move to make them regular
sign languages oh that's the one oh and
about another year i'm sure you gotta
listen you gotta bring the silence
oh my god i love uh doing this [ __ ] on
sunday and sometimes just giggling
so you got into it as a stand-up you
went to work with danny because you knew
crazy danny
we uh we talked about danny the week
after he died all right remember that
r.i.p i recently [ __ ] i loved them i
listened to that five times oh my god
that was one of the funniest things i
ever yeah you said yeah uh
he was he was a sick [ __ ] man he rest in
peace
that's the greatest
greatest transition ever in my life he
was
yeah he i i gotta be honest here
listen man i'm attracted to crazy people
crazy people seek me
that's who my mo is crazy people
attracted to crazy people you know
i liked him i liked him a lot he made me
laugh he was a hard nut to break in the
beginning it took me three years to get
in that club and even then he'd break my
[ __ ] balls rogan had to bring me in
then he would give me love and he was
really giving me love
then him and i hit it off and he was
good to me but everybody always thought
i did blow with the poor guy i never did
align with that guy it was crazy i knew
that if i carried him with me i couldn't
get rid of him
i knew that by his personality he liked
going out man that was his thing this is
yeah danmer tempi improv
he was he was the that's what he was
known for like he's the guy
he's going to take your party and he's
how you drinking you see there's a band
in town or he's got you know springsteen
tickets there's always something oh it
sounds like my worst nightmare
he's a party party he was a partier he
did the craziest [ __ ] man he went to the
bus that time with jimmy schubert carla
they went to like a gambling bust do you
remember that i didn't know i wasn't
there for you yeah i remember that i
remember they went to see bob dylan oh
so they rented a bus that you could
drink on and gamble on and do the
[ __ ] whole thing we were leaving the
improv he was getting there he was one
of those guys and you know what here's
the sad part about it that
troy's gonna
you know you're a good
you read character as well and you like
that
and this is what i read of dan i read
dan dan was the
slash
general manager of the tempe improv if
he was here in this room right now he'd
tell you he owned it plus the mall
you know
you know whatever but it didn't matter i
liked it
yeah dan was a lonely guy yeah he was
that's just
he wanted so badly to be a player
he wanted people to tell him he was
bigger than hartman he was trying to
find you know he gave a lot of people a
lot of money to make little investments
yeah on movies and [ __ ] and they [ __ ]
them you know yeah yeah no i heard that
he did a lot of that and he he really
did come from a good place on all of his
stuff yeah he had all his demons but man
he was
he was a lonely guy and he just wanted
to be
known like that magazine they wrote
about him he took that out and bronzed
it
oh put it right at the entrance when you
walked in yeah yeah yeah
it takes balls to hang
an article about yourself yeah
you want to hang it in your office
you know next to your trophies from
college i'm in
yeah but they're hanging up at the
business
he and it was huge it was the first
thing you [ __ ] saw i mean he was
really in love with it and i
i saw that but the last three years of
his life when i was involved with him
down there it was not good like the lat
not last three years the last
three times i'd gone to his club
i saw something that was completely
different he was gone
just and then the super bowl went down
there and he lost it
because he thought he was going to be
invited to all those parties oh but what
he didn't realize is
it's in phoenix
nobody's going to drive the tempi
he kept thinking oh my god all these
celebrities
are going to come to my club
nobody showed up not one person oh wow
they all stay in the [ __ ] hut by the
super bowl
you know what i'm saying that's where
they stay if you've been to a super bowl
they don't leave that [ __ ] village
yeah so
you know he got really disappointed
and i couldn't believe that that it's
like you really thought they were going
to come over here and get you yeah well
look at my picture on the wall i'm the
owner yeah well he you know he was uh
you do that stuff that kind of thing
like you know when you hear a comic walk
in and talk about where they've been in
their resume the first thing they say
it's like that doesn't come from a place
of having a big ego that comes from a
place of just somebody who's a little
bit terrified a little bit
insecure about what what's going on they
just haven't gotten comfortable you know
and so he had that and he you know that
was what he did he was a cockblocker
you could not talk to a woman at this
club
and you would try to justify it but then
one of the weirdest things happened
in 1998
99
way before i met my wife i went down
there
now at those times tempe improv was the
club you wanted to do well at
oh yeah because that's vegas that put
when you told people you worked weekends
in the 10 p.m probably huge because they
knew that the club was quality all the
way
you didn't slip through the [ __ ]
cracks there you know how i always say
that saying it's not how many people you
shoot it's who you shoot
you in 10 15 years ago
in
2099 98 97 if you had the tempi improv
on your resume you could sell yourself
into a lot of clubs as soon as you faxed
them your resume
they would bite because they knew it was
a militant club they knew that
you know david spade they taped the
[ __ ] specials there they did the
young comedian special there a lot of
people don't remember that with nick
apollo and andy candler and who's the
other louis ck no the director from
all those movies that works on avatar
you know that club had some heat to it
so would you put it down even even if
you had a bad set
oh no yeah it didn't matter you
performed yeah they're not going to
check they're not going to know
what they do when you did that no they
were like wow you performed that yeah
just the fact that you walked in there
and performed that that was like the
holy grail club that was the holy grail
yeah so i had worked there like twice i
had done a latino tour there one time
where they paid you 400 bucks and they
gave you a hotel room that night yeah
it's like joey medina yeah looking
knocked on my door
you're at the wrong [ __ ] door and oh
my god it was hard while i was coked up
she took me by storm then i sat there
for an hour going i should have hired
her like i'm like i should have hired
her she would have sucked my dad i
wasn't even thinking like i was so coked
up
it was an easy in and out it was easy
phoenix to la
and then i went down there and i forget
who the headliner was
and i went down there he called me and
he goes can you make it down here by
thursday uh wednesday night you know
at that time i didn't have a resume i'd
done like mad tv
and maybe analyzed that and it was big
to me like i was like [ __ ] december
it's going to be all over when otherwise
that comes out
and he called me he goes come on down
and guys at that time
i was living on the couch
sometimes in the car
i had no confidence you know like girl
confidence
i was just trying to he was paying 550 i
think
i would just try to get coke two of the
nights i was there and
that was my big thing if i could eat and
just i would buy two shirts when i was
there from a fat man store or something
in phoenix and i was pretty happy with
that you know and i go down there
thursday night and jesus christ i get
off stage i remember the green room was
upstairs
yeah upstairs way deep yeah deep leave
they had to [ __ ] get a treasure map
to find that [ __ ] way way way at the
end of the way at the end of the map i'm
sitting there waiting for the headline
because you can walk out and watch the
headline yeah so at first when the
waitresses were busy i wouldn't want to
go out there so i would wait till like
20 minutes and then go out there and
watch the headliner for a while i hear
boom boom boom boom boom boom boom door
i open the [ __ ] door and that's a
broad jack
at the club at the club at the door i'm
a feature act on a thursday night
and this or it could have been friday it
could have been thursday or friday
because i had to live there with another
night and danny was mad and they didn't
know if i was fired and all this [ __ ] so
i'm not the girl's talking to me she's a
little bit [ __ ] drunk she's telling
me about coke and her girlfriends and
blah blah blah and i go listen yeah it
had to be thursday because i go with the
show's gonna end and we could still go
to a bar
so now it's
20 minutes from that situation happened
the girl goes downstairs guess who comes
up danny murr
and he wants to take me out he wants to
go partying
and i'm like i just told this [ __ ]
girl
they're young
they're young girls they
they were from jersey yeah it was just
there was some stupid connection
you know and they're like we want to go
huh we got blow
because i must have talked about coke on
stage so he's in there now telling me
how we're gonna go to this place and the
car is coming and they have a great
[ __ ] cocktail
but i'm like i'm not up to all that [ __ ]
do you want to take me to scottsdale and
that's the big thing like go to
scottsdale to be around yep
with the lines and the short skirts and
the boom the techno [ __ ] so i look them
right in the face and i go hey man
i i'm gonna go back to my hotel room
to the condo
i go i'm really tired man
and he goes really i go yeah
i go home here a couple nights i'll go
out with you
and he goes okay and guess what happens
what
i opened up the door and now the girl's
up there with three other broads tits
out of their shirts banging
two of them are married and they want to
do powder
and they're like looking at me and i'm
like
and they're like we're still going out
let's go we got a car let's go we
already called we got julio waiting for
us at the bar right around leona yeah i
don't know what his name is no there was
julio's it was a main kitchen guy it was
a two it was two blocks away from that
improv there was like a little bar
and
now i got damn there i just lied to
[ __ ] dan my boss
that i was going home to sleep so i get
myself out of i go you know what i was
going to go home to sleep you know what
[ __ ] it let's all go out i go damn you
want to go out with us he goes well i
got these people waiting i go damn one
of them is my cousin i forgot all about
it dad i'm gonna have to go out with
them
and he goes well [ __ ] it then i'll go
out with you
i mean he was that much of a child he
was 10 years older than i was
and he wanted to go hang out with these
[ __ ] girls if i was 30 something
these girls were 28 i was maybe 38 this
is how long ago this was this is 16
[ __ ] years ago i'm 50 [ __ ] three
so i was 37. these girls like 30 and
[ __ ] dan's 50 [ __ ] something years
old looking like bozo with his hair he's
bald he won't shave the whole thing he's
got these curly things looking like
kleinfeld from [ __ ] carlito's way
these girls are looking at him like you
got to bring him with us
and i'm like listen i don't [ __ ] know
the headliner still had a half hour
so i go dad why don't you go downstairs
let me finish what i'm doing here and
we'll all meet
so dan's downstairs trying to be fancy
with the four girls telling them he owns
the club he get them deals to go to a
room but i'm getting sick to my [ __ ]
stomach
i look at the chick that's got the blog
oh you want to do some [ __ ] bad i go
because the girl's bathroom was upstairs
there was one downstairs but there was
one upstairs but there was a line
remember there used to be a line i go go
upstairs to the girls bathroom
and go right to the [ __ ] green room
and she goes to the green room i give it
two minutes
i run upstairs to the green room i get
upstairs to the [ __ ] green room we're
doing [ __ ] bumps
we're doing bumps she's putting [ __ ]
coke on her tits i'm snorting the coke
off it tits like commando style the
nipple's still in the shirt i'm just
throwing it up here i didn't give a [ __ ]
what she did i just wanted to snort coke
i didn't want to [ __ ] her down like that
well i did that that wasn't the point
then she finally popped one of those
jugs out i'm sucking on them putting
coke on it she's got a bag of [ __ ]
coke
i mean this [ __ ] had you know maybe
eight grams of coke and she's throwing
coke on it like [ __ ] uh
what's his name in the in the in the
[ __ ] uh what's the movie with jack
nicholson in boston where he's the mob
boss
the party he's throwing cocaine at him
she's strong i mean this chick was crazy
i'm sucking her titties i'm fingering
the whole thing i got him in the
mountain position
i mean this is terrible we're starting
to blow i got coke all over my face now
this obviously is the size of this
[ __ ] table
oh lee this office is the size of this
table well guess what happens danny
walks in oh no oh [ __ ] and you know how
that goes now with him he couldn't just
walk out and go downstairs
he embarrasses the girl
he says that this isn't this type of
club that when he brought me in he had
he would fire me but he likes me
personally so the rest of the weekend
i'm on probation that he might find me
i'm listening to this [ __ ] going what
type of guy would give you this [ __ ]
here beating
only somebody who doesn't like somebody
having fun a real guy would lock the
door and go the next day go that was
crazy what the [ __ ] were you doing up
there joey you know whatever he just
embarrassed me embarrassed the girl blew
the whole [ __ ] night
i do the rest of the week and i go back
i call him and i'm hearing rumors from
people
you're banned because he caught you
sleeping with somebody and if i wasn't
sleeping with it
i was friggin i was sucking the tits and
we were doing blow there was nothing
going on
there was nothing going on that's first
base where i come from
the [ __ ] kind of people nice to meet you
so that was it i was bad i wasn't really
banned he was just mad at me you know
why he's not mad because you did because
you're doing that in the office he's mad
because he wouldn't include him like if
you would have said hey i got this chick
this bra she's gonna blow everybody
and she's got coke throw under her
titties when i went upstairs i didn't
think that was a thing i just wanted to
do bloat
in those days i probably had a little
blow in my pocket but if she was
offering i was snorting it because it
was [ __ ] uh arizona coke it was right
there just came over the border it just
got off the mule you know what i'm
saying the mexicans just dropped it off
in the mule right down the corner there
in tucson it's still in the saddle it's
still in the saddlebag you know i would
get coke down there that was and
everybody was doing coke
i remember i remember taking joe rogan
joe rogan taking me to a club one night
and looking at joe's face after an hour
he had gone to the bathroom twice
and he's like everybody in this [ __ ]
town does cocaine
and i'm sitting there with him sober as
a judge going i know i would be doing it
too but you sit the cross on me you [ __ ]
i'd be in that bathroom vacuuming it up
with those savages
he took me to another party one time uh
the porno girl before she married tito
ortiz yeah jenna jameson she's coming to
the club all the time used to come into
the improv all the time and i went to a
house one time and i got to tell you
something you know i'm a dirty guy you
hear me
her house was beautiful like she had a
gorgeous home with the original husband
yeah
it was just filled with disgust you
could smear you could smell this burn
particles floating in the air oh come on
it was just the i went there for a party
i went there for a party
and everybody's doing blow and me and
joe trying to be cool and i can't take
it no more this girl finally takes me to
the room and we're snorting coke and
when i come out joe was there
and joe saw it i felt [ __ ] terrible
but joe this is what these parties are
about
and there was some chick sucking her own
tits you know it was just a crazy this
type of house it was a porno house it
ain't my type of house that was what's
her name's house yeah she would go to
the improv a lot huh yeah she's coming
along i just thought she was just going
to see joe rogan and stuff yeah she she
always came in for joe but like we'd see
her in there once a while i i want to
say this was the tito days but i at that
time i didn't know no
she had the original husband yeah
because this is like the you know 2002
2001 2002 2003.
yeah i don't remember who she was but
yeah she used to come in and then the
guy nils lofgren yeah used to come in a
lot yeah he was friends with uh yeah
with dan love dan dan make sure you know
sent him a lot of food it was it was the
big stress night with nils lofgren's
here it was like a big [ __ ] deal you
know everything shuts down everyone's on
military rules you know
it was crazy i hated bosses like that in
those places oh but dan was a celebrity
he was a celebrity guy he made sure that
he loved all that [ __ ] it was like then
schindler's list when the guy said hey
send the nuts he's another extra bottle
of champagne like he was that guy
exactly he was that guy oh [ __ ] yeah he
did he did some stuff that i hated i
look back now and i go all right i kind
of get that that was brilliant it was me
he he was mean and brilliant and here's
what i mean he had he used to hire
people he'd put an ad in the paper and
he'd say come tomorrow come monday uh
between one and five all these people
say 100 people show up sometimes more
than that 100 people show up on monday
and they're waiting they wait there from
one to five
and uh
someone calls at 1 30 comes out
hey hey guys uh just dan is on his way
uh so please hang tight and so he'd call
in and just sound keep keep him waiting
keep him wait he keeping that five
o'clock he's still not there
and uh so i'll come back tomorrow they
have employee come out
next day
same thing happens
now it's 60 people shooting like fight
club
what it's like fight club you have to
stand on the he made people wait and
then they come tuesday and he every hour
someone comes hey he's going to be here
soon he never shows up they do it again
wednesday
and then thursday and here's what
happens it starts with 100 next day is
60 then it's 40 then it's 20 then it's
10. the p the last 10 people show up he
hires all 10.
i hated that but then i look back and go
that [ __ ] guy he wanted the people
that wanted the job really [ __ ] bad
because he knew that those are good
employees it's pretty [ __ ] smart it
took me a long time to figure out that's
what he was doing
i get it but for a whole week and like
no it's he ruined people's lives for a
[ __ ] week he made him wait and it was
for like a like a server job or like a
doorman job a server job door yeah the
whole [ __ ] thing oh my god yeah
no it's kind of [ __ ] crazy that's too
much yeah that's
i've heard of things like
they'll reschedule it a couple times on
you
just to see if you if you make it like
but i would like
to be honest i wouldn't have gotten a
job there i i wouldn't yeah no all were
left after the first day yeah no me too
i left that for the first day that's
just embarrassing that you wait four
hours and that's just so now you broke
up with dan you and dan go [ __ ] it and
you came to l.a you were working with
dan uh yeah i was worried about you
it was he's kind of what drove me like i
was so frustrated with
he was such a tyrant it kind of made me
move to la it kind of got made me go i
got to get the [ __ ] out so like it was
like 2003 i moved out
and what did you do in 2003 you were
doing stand up i was doing stand up and
that person yeah that's what and that
that's what i thought i want to do when
i came out here and then uh
i uh i somebody had to have me tape
something i got a video camera i started
making little short films and stuff like
that and i got i got real i loved
i love making things and you can call it
producing which that's what it's called
that's cool
like it's not just about making stuff
like we all have our thing that we're
making you're making you're making
brilliant stuff on stage connecting with
an audience and making people feel like
life is [ __ ] normal in america when
there's all this pc [ __ ] like you're
giving that to people it's all about
what do you make and i i liked making
things that other people could could
join in on like get get i want to get my
friends together we're going to make
this move we're going to do this thing i
like that [ __ ] so that's what drove me
into all of it you know
and you created set list yeah now what
is the whole purpose of settlers tell
the people at home if they don't know
it's an improvised stand-up show where
uh you walk on stage instead of
doing any material you've ever done you
get a set list of really strange
sometimes nonsense [ __ ] up topics you
get them in the moment and then you act
like that's the act you've been doing on
the road for 10 years but they flipped
the the subjects yeah you get like five
different things that's what [ __ ] my
world up there i thought the concept was
brilliant
i just you did the show
and and you were amazing and first of
all here's you know what happened
tonight you were we did a seven o'clock
and nine o'clock and if you've ever done
those the seven o'clock is always [ __ ]
because the audience is it's seven
there's daylight out
every time we did the early taping for
all those every day we did early the
audience was terrible and the comics
left going man i just didn't feel like i
really got him and the late show was
[ __ ] incredible do you still do the
setlist there yeah so well we still do
it there and then it became a tv show in
the uk and australia and then
we
been torn around a bunch of different
places so you were saying chile and
edinburgh argentina and with edinboro
and it's it's regular australia so it's
all over the place but it's a it's a
sort of a thing designed to get people
out of their orbit like
we all have a routine
and and uh that those butterflies and
that adrenaline all that like you know
those times where you're on stage you
don't have that like and it's it's like
you're going through the routine and the
audience is loving it but then you leave
stage and you're like i don't know if i
i don't have that like i just [ __ ]
wheeled out a safe feeling you know and
set list kind of guarantees that you're
going to feel that because it triggers
that adrenaline because you're you're
out of control you have no control over
what's happening and you have to you're
getting stuff thrown at you it's like
the beginning of that kung fu it is like
kung fu in the beginning in 2008 when i
first got off cocaine
my mind started going through different
directions and i was like you know what
in 10 years the stand-up shit's going to
be boring i love when i get a call from
a comic
who's put a new pitch together for a
stand-up show
in those days i used to get them once a
[ __ ] month from some goofy
[ __ ]
that wants me to meet him somewhere to
put uh you know something together
for a typical
three of us are gonna go on stage and
then i'm gonna host and there's gonna be
strippers you know
three of us are gonna go on stage and
there's gonna be people with drums or
people playing the saxophone behind you
i mean
there was a thousand concepts but they
all
went back to just doing stand-up yeah
and i [ __ ] was getting sick of it i
go something has to change
something has to [ __ ] change
and uh people were trying little things
i cut you contacted me i went down i was
still on the [ __ ] comatose stage when
i went down there and i wasn't really
feeling it that night
but when i left there i remember going
jesus christ somebody is thinking like
i'm thinking
that this could go into so many [ __ ]
directions to stand up instead of the
this is a tv show i can't believe it
yeah well that's thanks to paul provenza
i mean he's yeah he's he you know he's
he's [ __ ] incredible with all the
projects he does and so he you know we
took it edinburgh it got picked up for a
show we did uh 14 episodes and it was
you know it was amazing it was it was a
complete blast you know good for you man
yeah it was great and and you know what
what it did though is like like we we
did the melbourne festival and i had a
guy come up after the show and he goes
hey i want he goes because it was
showing it went into reruns and like it
was it's still going in australia it's
ridiculous
this guy he goes he goes i came in
because my kid he's in the sixth grade
he started a setlist club at his school
i was like i was complete like like my
life changed that that was the moment i
went oh my god that's incredible he
started a setless club at school so
i think what that's gonna do for those
kids like they're gonna get to feel like
to to learn that when you get thrown
into it situated into that pit where
you're afraid and you confront every
demon it's just like this thing
you can just do that and not be afraid
and get used to like you said like you
got addicted to that it's the same
[ __ ] thing right it's getting
addicted to that adrenaline but finding
a new way to get there's no way to get
to it monday night i did something that
was the most interesting i think i've
done in a while
i didn't want to do it
it was in my realm i'm not going to lie
to anybody but i did not want to do it
well he caught me in a weird time in my
life and i said sure
and for three weeks i sat in my [ __ ]
office sweating it
and i just started getting ready last
week i agreed to do the goddamn comedy
jam oh wow that's the greatest show with
the with [ __ ] from baltimore
and i love him i've known him a long
time you know what's his name josh adams
oh yeah
yeah he's doing i got there with lee i
got to be honest i didn't know what to
expect
you're going to put it on firmly i have
it if you want yeah put it on from see
if he's got it you have it on your phone
on my computer all right then do it yeah
put it on from then you could cut it up
later and release it what what is this
this is the goddamn damn comedy
i've seen that show that is one of them
so i went down and i looked around he
goes are you gonna sing a song i said
yeah
i didn't get a chance to rehearse it i
was busy moving last monday so
i love that you did this i couldn't go
down there and uh
i went down and i gotta tell you
something i was so blown away you wanna
talk about [ __ ] anxiety oh yeah
i wanna i haven't seen it i saw what
adam posted
i got a dose of anxiety handed to me
and i felt it as soon as they said my
name i heard the music
i walked up to the stage
and i didn't focus on josh adam myers i
focused on the drummer
for some reason something just said joey
don't do it and i focused on the drama
focused on the drama [ __ ] put it play it
lee
focused on the drum focused on the drum
until i finally
turned and when i turned
troy conrad
reality at its finest
oh man i love that you did this joey
so there's this big crowd the band uh
i think all these episodes of this show
can be i don't know if this one's on
comedy central
but
you can watch them on comedy central
joey's out there dancing this is
unbelievable they can see it
everyone can see this yeah okay
oh my god how cool is it right this is
unbelievable
joey looks like he's always been a rock
star
holy [ __ ]
is
this is unbelievable
ah
joey's absorbing all that energy putting
it all out
yeah right i have anxiety
to the gills really i can't breathe
i'm just playing it right there i'm just
trying to really be cool you came out
right you look like you're in the zone
oh look now you're okay i'm trying to
get my head together
oh now you're back
sure i came back i had no [ __ ] choice
amazing
oh
holy [ __ ]
please do this every week joey
oh [ __ ]
you know the balls just took to do this
guys
i was sweating at the last day
you want to run out of there while
you're waiting
like just like maybe something maybe the
stage will collapse
no i just sat there with lee like a
warmer drinking beer
he's having a good time he knows i'm
sitting here in faith
look at josh out of mind he's such a
prince
oh man he is unbelievable
that's the greatest thing i've ever seen
i think look at that dude behind me look
how lit up the audience is
holy [ __ ] yeah yeah the guy behind you
oh my god he's the guy from the movie
with denzel washington right yeah
legalizer
joey you're a monster up there
the end is the best
oh my god only lee would take this so
embarrass me oh
please tell me joey you're going to be
doing this again
i don't know what song you could do
this is easier
oh
all right lee release this to the realm
let's fix it up nice cut it up nice
make a video win an academy award
oh my god
joey's beautiful it was a lot of fun man
there's jeremiah watkins
i'm so happy oh yeah of course i have to
tape that one suck my dick oh let me
give some shout outs yeah
my main man ali buzz up there starting
jiu jitsu
dante gazzini thank you for the cd [ __ ]
sucker
johnny cutler
up there arse warrior
danny staples ash man tv
one by one podcast my main man
mikey klein but he's not jewish
and hiro jr which i missed completely
they were at the vote see i had my dates
all [ __ ] up i thought they were coming
in the 29th
so i took a sunday at the comedy store
last sunday i was gonna go from there to
the viper room
and surprise them they weren't there
they were there the 31st which was
wednesday
so what happened was
wednesday i had to dig up at the ice
house
i didn't get out of there till 11
o'clock so i never got to see hero
junior but i heard they're ripping up
the f i heard they ripped up the [ __ ]
viper room
the 911 had to come people were jumping
up and down jews on fire the whole thing
the whole [ __ ] thing
so now you're in that way you do the set
list yeah okay can i ask you something
though because because i i really do
hope i would love to see you do i know
you don't do those specialty shows you
like you like doing the real [ __ ] and
but this like this worked so good for
you like this was unbelievable because
it was only four sentences
that i had to repeat four eight or 12
times i just took the notes from
imdb.com right
oh but you know that last line [ __ ] you
i won't do it to tell me they wrote that
for me
that's the thing my mom told me since
day one so it came out it just flowed
organically
sucked my dick all that stuff
[ __ ] that comes out again i
picked the best song for myself yeah
this was it this was like so now i got
to pick another one i don't know what to
pick now i gotta [ __ ] think about it
alonzo did fight the power i gotta get i
gotta do stuff to rile up the crowd i
gotta let them leave they're going jesus
[ __ ] christ could you do an ac dc
no really
i feel like you could do it
i could do an ace my favorite ac dc
aren't the [ __ ] that most radio people
listen to
i was a back and black guy
but when i think ac dc now i like power
range
i'm a real big guy with a hell guy oh
yeah i like that oh yeah listen
night prowler
is a great song i can't hold it up
walk all over you i would [ __ ] your
world up that would that would give me a
heart attack on stage why because it'd
be two guitar dueling and [ __ ] if i
could get a really good top player to do
the goddamn you gotta do it sing it yeah
that would be unbelievable i mean that's
sing it slow take it over oh i love all
that [ __ ]
i love when
people listen
i don't give a [ __ ] if you
do somebody's song
but if you do it do it do me a favor
put your flavor on to it show me why you
did
if you're gonna you know if you're gonna
do to make mechanic over
show me why your version is better than
his charles bronson
that's all i want you to do if you're
gonna get the balls to do my song over
show me why you were doing it over yeah
zeppelin stole your song you know why he
stole it because you're a sleeping pill
that's why i led zeppelin i heard that
stay where the hell that would stay
where the hell because it was so [ __ ]
bad
you know who heard that song you sang
nobody three people on a nasty trip in
malibu that's it zeppelin heard it and
said this guy's [ __ ] watch this bam
lit that [ __ ] up on fire that
became what it was that's why the jury
said what are you [ __ ] kidding me
this was a and b this song put you to
sleep and that's why harry krishna's got
together this is how bad your music is
absolutely got to make it your own so
that's the problem there so yeah
so you get that right now you do the set
list it's doing well
yeah you pick up a camera one day to
[ __ ] take pictures for the set list
and voila yeah and then i got i just got
super into photography man i got i got
in how long ago was this how many years
well settlers been six years so that's
when i first got but and i'd say in the
last like
four or five years is when i just got
obsessed i saw something pictures from
montreal with felicia you up there oh
yeah yeah
yeah i love felicia uh and she's she was
doing amazing work up there too she was
doing pictures like we're both in that
photography it's the same you know i
think it's
so similar to comedy it's all about
lenses it's all about how you see
something a little bit different i mean
photography and comedy are really
similar that way you know like
we all have our own lens that's what's
really exciting a photographer goes oh
my god you know you can do with this
lens you can practically see in the
[ __ ] dark and everything on the back
glows
when you're going in and talking about
something on stage nobody else can do
when you have a point of view like
you're the ultimate example of like a
real point of view in [ __ ] comedy
nobody can ever like copy that because
it would look so everyone go oh yeah i
know exactly who that is like that's so
simple
to recognize because you
you have that about you it's the same
thing with with cameras yeah you make me
look handsome
your pictures i got three i got two my
daughter carries one of the pictures
it's not even framed that's lee she
walks around with the one picture you
took oh oh that's cool yeah so she likes
your stuff i got the other one that you
mailed this yeah so for everyone who
doesn't know troy's the one who does all
the all the really cool black and white
design the front up uh the new hall of
fame for pictures you design well yeah
this so is the hall series but it's uh
it's on permanent exhibit in the uh
lobby of the main room at the comedy
store so there's about 80 comics joey
you were the first person i photographed
thank you because nobody ever thinks of
me and that's what i'm saying like
this time dog
i kept a joke
because of you
i kept a joke that i [ __ ] thought was
disgusting as i was saying it but it
worked for the moment where i was
wiped you know sometimes i paint myself
into a wall at the store
and i know how to get myself out of it
because it's the [ __ ] original room i
[ __ ] hate the main room
i hate the main room i go to the main
room i go like that like those people
and gladiator i know
i got a 40 chance of dying but it's
higher than that yeah because i lose my
confidence right in the middle of like
why am i here why the [ __ ] am i in the
main room i'm an original i am
connecting
from the original room when i walked
into the original room i knew it was
going to be my home when i walked into
seattle underground when i saw those
water bugs i go this is this is it this
is it this is what i want
this these new clubs are opening and
they're fancy schmancy that's not
standard tablecloth i can't wait till
somebody goes you know what i'm opening
up a comedy club and i want the people
to smoke i don't care if the place burns
down that's what you know how many
people would hang out and they could
smuggly and put their feet up and watch
three or four comics do 45
a lot
a lot get really good food yeah yes a
steak uh finger food not even a steak
like you know
clams and zucchini sticks and uh yeah
pizza pizza no no pizza [ __ ] it up
we went and got pizza the other day and
you know where did you get
and it wasn't bad
but again like i tell liam lee's
learning if i'm gonna eat garbage i want
it to be memorable garbage
does that make sense yeah yeah yeah i
went last night and i had one of the
best meals i've ever had
i wanted to thank lee last night i went
to a place that he turned me on to that
i would like to go in there hit firewood
nah he turned me on to that mexican
place on moore park we didn't eat dinner
so i called my wife on the way back to
the store i'm gonna go get tacos she
just bring me two of them
i got two carnita tacos with avocado and
cheese
cactus those [ __ ] take it to
the hoop right there in moore park so if
i'm gonna cheat i'm not gonna cheat big
i'm just looking at two tacos i didn't
get the rice i didn't get to do
something again [ __ ] i drank water when
i got home with two [ __ ] tacos that
was my dinner basically my point being
that
the other day the baby likes pizza i
like pizza
lee likes pizza last week me and lee
struck the cord with pizza and holly we
went to joe's pizza on the way up the
hill
delicious it's great pizza they make it
perfect nice to chin
we couldn't finish it we weren't even
hungry we still got a slice in three
quarters we ate we threw it away
now that put the flavor i grew up on
pizza i grew up on a slice of day
i slayed listen most societies an apple
a day keeps the doctor away or i grew up
a slice a day keeps everything away vd
gonorrhea the [ __ ] mumps just cheese
too just cheese that's it all you need
it's a tune-up absolutely i don't have a
tune up here you know the tune-up is a
two o'clock slice
with a diamond coke
that's a tune-up and it's if it's lint
maybe a white pie with some mussels with
marinara on it
so yeah you want to like these [ __ ]
premier photographers now in comedy well
yeah i love doing it man i love getting
stuff it's just a it's an obsession you
know last night i look up and i see you
there for two seconds i get pissed off
oh yeah i see you
i i saw you there and i got pissed off
for two seconds like what detroit
comrade
well last night yeah i was like that's
it that's right when most people do it i
kind of go
well no that now i last night i was
there and i was helping brenton who's
the uh is a great comic and also handles
the social media for uh for the common
store he uh i was helping him set up his
camera because he's got this great new
camera so i i help him do the settings
so we can get right so we were i was
just kind of playing around with this
camera so i got some shots of you and i
i know he took some great ones so
he was uh i just showed him stuff
by the way
i love seeing what happens when people
figure out how to use like a you know
dsl they don't mean anything it's just a
it's like really a confusing ball like i
don't need this [ __ ] i got a phone that
takes good pic when you start learning
how to use that stuff and the like the
cool [ __ ] that you can do
he he lit up he was so excited he was
like starts playing with stuff it was
great
i love that
you know i i sorry i go i get crazy
you're weirded out on this gadgety guy
like yeah i do like gagging and
especially cameras no no i haven't done
friends
i had a friend that i used to [ __ ]
drive to california with
every 90 days from seattle i love him
dealing one of the funniest guys i've
ever met i learned a lot from him about
manhood funnel
he was a lot older than i was he was
black i loved him but he was a
photographer and
this i used he used to call me
he would let me get under his skin
so when you let me get under your skin
guess what i do in a loving way i get
under your skin
so he would show me his pictures and
what he would basically do is take a
camera from 1950 a box camera
yeah and when he go on the road he'd go
to rural roads
and he'd take these gorgeous pictures of
uh
broken down cars and broken down
tractors with a pig next to it
and they were beautiful pictures but
then he'd do something i didn't like
he'd fill him in with like a stencil
to give it that 3d look and he'd kill
the pictures his pictures were beautiful
when you looked at his pictures he
always picked something up that was just
wild he never
picked the chicken up and put it there
or put a leaf there
he always caught that third thing yeah
so i think that's important in
photography i look at pictures he
catches that third angle
yeah yeah i don't even know if it exists
it's something i see in my world that
i've always called the third it's kind
of like an extra dimension i know what
you mean like it's something extra but
that picture you can't always describe
it but you go ah it's just i [ __ ]
like that
and that as a former like film student
who like
in those classes people would make make
make movies i don't like calling them
films
and they'd be like i'm gonna make this
black and white for like artistic yeah
reasons
it's very artistic i don't feel like
you're doing it for that reason i feel
like
i mean i feel like it definitely is
artistic
but i don't feel like you're doing it to
be like
really like fancy or some things just
seem comprised
when i see it coming it pisses me off as
a professional yeah uh
contrived scripted totally lee and i did
uh something one night a podcast and we
had a comic go on there
and every response
was scripted
oh
it was
no
so let's say i would ask you about
uh yeah wait go ahead and ask me i'll do
a scripted response no so i would say so
anything about photography and ego
photography is great uh
but i went to see my doctor he just go
in oh nobody monologue and me and lee
were like oh
no
it's called the byron allen
that's called i call it the byron allen
oh jesus christ
like when you do that rehearsal you go
right you start with something and you
go right
sounds very memorized right
people don't know what we're talking
about at home a lot of times not anymore
yeah it stopped about 10 years ago for
me
but before that there was a lot of
places you go in
and they need to make you do two things
a write down your lead-ins to jokes
and it was horrifying
they had wait they had you write down
your lead inside
okay so
so if you had a joke about clouds what
sound do not joke about doing coke with
the cats okay or that'll say so i
wouldn't say that i wouldn't say that i
go
let's talk about my cats
and let's talk about uh sleep apnea
okay and they go nuts okay and he'd go
uh you could still get it but we don't
need it right now and he'd go
so uh this weekend we have a
a very funny guy here at the [ __ ]
copper kettle you know because there's a
i would always play those sea rooms
and then the guy went you know
uh chubby coco diaz uh very interesting
uh we also have the green bay packers
are in town and they would go like well
and also
so joey what do you think about cats and
it would sound
horrific
oh because nobody was talking about
[ __ ] cats stupid in fact we weren't
even talking about anything remotely
close to a [ __ ] currency [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you know it was [ __ ] like that when you
watch byron allen on the sports show at
1am that comes on at 2 am there's a
reason why they put it on at 2am it's
because of his segways
i understand
i understand comics need money and
comics needs stage time in a forum
but i couldn't imagine like i had one of
the worst club owners go off on me one
time about that
but i didn't talk about what i gave the
guy the guy goes the guy was throwing
you your material you weren't doing it i
go because my [ __ ] materials dirty
i thought i was coming in here to talk
and tell them about myself and sell
myself that's how you sell tickets
no we here at this club we want you to
do material on the raid it was [ __ ]
horribly
that's a byron allen lee it's the most
unorganic thing
you've ever seen in your life
so how long have you been taking
pictures for
well uh
i mean it's been
seven years yeah yeah about six seven
years but yeah the last like like the
last four so what happened the last time
you photographed sheep
and you're like i would uh i think that
i hate sheep i went to long i went to
anybody here from oh yeah
that's how oh yeah he would throw it in
late
if you watch tonight stay up monday
night and watch whatever the show is
called byron allen so they would they
would take the thing you say how long
four to five years and the person will
go yes i yeah four or five years and uh
which reminds me my mother-in-law she's
you know she's always doing so like and
so is that how they do it they're like
doing the weird segways when you have a
inexperienced emcee or an inexperienced
dj whatever they want to call themselves
they don't have the stage time
they're not really they're not really
wordsmiths
you follow me you know i'm not a
wordsmith but i've learned how to put
words in certain places lee telling me
you the online league was you had a good
set but you said [ __ ] a couple times
too many
that's a wordsmith
that's somebody who goes and listens to
that tape and he goes you were right
in fact there i should use uh
emotionally challenged
there i should use mentally challenged
you follow me that's a wordsmith so you
don't say it twice uh why would i say
[ __ ] on this joke where it really hits
on this joke i'll say something
different on this joke you know if you
work with some comedy writers like
willie marcena yeah love william you'll
die
because he breaks it down to the t yeah
so you're ending about a musical album
and then he'll put a word at the end of
that bit to make it go in so when you
shoot your special you have six things
to hit and they'll come to you he's
telling me here on the show last week
how he goes by feeling just like actors
he's not he doesn't want you to recite
the material he wants you to remember
the feelings you have when you say those
material jesus christ
yeah that makes sense that's it and i
thought about it i went up and did sets
with him friday night my first set was
horrendous horrendously bad i got people
to laugh but i knew it wasn't what i
wanted to do
my second set because i thought about
what he said
i want you to put yourself there
and i want you to do 20 minutes on
whatever you go
and it was perfect
i haven't listened to the tape we're
going to meet tomorrow to listen to the
tape he's got notes the whole [ __ ] so
you're going oh you're going by feeling
as you're going through it
why not yeah the times i do better is
when i go to the comp listen when you go
to the comedy store and you sit in the
back and you got to follow a [ __ ]
uh what's his name that i told you was
there last night from america's funniest
comics
the good-looking kid i forgot the blonde
kitten rogan and greg fitzsimmons and
also and you got to go up there you got
to outdo these guys
so
sometimes i trick them with energy
it's that anger mixed with energy that
really gets their attention gets them
[ __ ] hopping in their chairs
that's what gets people ba boom yeah
that's why i got to take him for the
special i love i love watching you walk
on the problem is right it's it's taken
nobody's gonna do it for 50 60 minutes
yeah so i got to find a strategy just
like conor mcgregor did against diaz
you follow me
for eight take him in for 12.
[ __ ] throw
a rant at him rightly
pull it back for eight take him into
something else and then close on a
[ __ ] rant that gets everybody's hair
going up and that's it that's the
strategy that you go into these specials
i never want to do anything like this
well because you like being organized
and you in theory could organize your
special by the minute
oh yeah no no lee i could organize all
that stuff it requires something
that i've never put into comedy
work work
you mean the sit you sit you don't want
to sit down i've always been a very lazy
comedian and that's why i got lazy
results for 15 and 16 years
it wasn't until i put a little extra
effort in it
and now what i'm doing with willie
really you know when you work with these
guys at a wordsmith
you just it's not that they give you
jokes it's that they teach you how to
come up with more jokes for that topic
before willie give will he'll do an hour
special talk about two things and you're
like wow
he beat that guy for 28 minutes a piece
yeah he beat those [ __ ] jokes
what's going on here there's those
noises up uh above you here yeah that
just sounds like somebody walking
or a water tank possibly breaking
it's definitely the water tank
salud [ __ ]
how you like me now
we gotta wake this podcast up see that's
how you restore energy there you go you
got energy back you get a little bomb on
people they come back they come back
with laughs
right now lisa has an anxiety attack he
can't wait to see what my ass i just
don't want to smell it i'm just blowing
i'm just breathing in through my mouth
and out of my nose
you're doing the opposite belize yeah
i'm doing i'm doing anti-bullies
oh my god
i just all i had to do was bring the
candle a little closer
it burned it off where it got to me no
you brought the candle closer it smelled
good so i wanted to breathe into my nose
oh my god i'm happy you came on troy
conrad yeah i'm honored you had me oh
the joke i love you guys the joke went
there yeah the joke that you said to me
that one night that i had forgotten i
said it
i had i was just on a [ __ ] energy
tear up on stage it was a thursday or
tuesday night
and lee was there and i don't know what
made me said i said i walked into that
room and all that was was blood and fest
and feathers
you haven't been doing that no oh my god
oh my god man i think i did it on the
last cd oh
i have to check i didn't have to check
the visuals like you're you're a painter
up there so you're painting this picture
for everybody and it's amazing but you
can see the reaction of people like when
you paint something that visual everyone
gets it it's in their body like they
jump and they it's so great to see that
and you you do that all the time so i'm
glad that that that helped because
when i watch you afterwards i i got your
your your bits are floating around my
head like i'm i'm laughing all night
because like i can't get that picture
out of my head you sent it back to me i
couldn't even walk to the car i was
laughing so hard oh that's amazing
because i didn't didn't feel what i said
when i
came out but it was true it was blood
and feathers and you said it to me when
you go blood and feathers really jelly
and i was like
oh my god that's terrible i forgot all
about that troll right that's my
favorite
i go with such a bad joke it's [ __ ]
good somewhere i'm laughing my [ __ ]
to the car and that's what you know
you're a fan
listen man
there's nothing
it doesn't bother me
but i can't figure out why people do it
what's that
what happened today today i was in jiu
jitsu i'm sitting there i'm breathing i
take my gear off i'm about to take my
[ __ ] pants off and my knee pads and i
look up and this kid looks over
and he walks over and he goes hey man
i just want to thank you for the podcast
blah blah blah blah
how's lee doing you know there's people
that talk to me and i could tell that if
they listen to the podcast one time
or if they listen to the podcast it's so
weird yeah yeah i could oh yeah they
come up to you differently yeah some guy
came up to me at the ice house the other
night how's lee doing with that mexican
chick bro
she's smacking them around yet bro and
we were laughing our asses off that's
he's gonna [ __ ] him up bro my friend
he dates a little chubby jewish guy too
bro she [ __ ] him up bro
we were dying i was at the lies house
died my god
you know when people know that much
about your personal life oh yeah they
know everything they're involved and you
always come up to me and go hey man that
episode you did with that guy and
sometimes you're the one that says
you're i'm behind two episodes
but i did listen to the rudy sod and i'm
like
this guy's really listening to it
sometimes you don't think you're doing a
good job or sometimes me and lee coming
here listen not all the podcasts can be
knowledgeable not all of them can be
very funny
there's some podcast that you're doing
here but sometimes there's always a
message with the podcast so you at least
get that from that's the most important
thing and today's
you say
and i gotta tell you something because
you were talking about it
i've been here for 20 years next year
and i've seen people come and go and
i've seen people come and go for the
worst excuses in the [ __ ] world
and i always look at myself i lived in a
car i took showers in the main room you
do know that right oh you should go
there at [ __ ] 8 30 before the show
started at 9.
i'd run back there with a black bag
and just shower wash my balls powder
myself put gel in my hair take a [ __ ]
they had the great bathroom in the back
right behind the main the whole time
you're washing you're scared because a
ghost is gonna [ __ ] you in the ass
you have no [ __ ] idea when you're
taking a shower at the county so i did
that every night like
you gotta go in there on the dock
because i had to be out of there by the
time the main room started
and there was always the black night on
tuesday nights you had something in
there on wednesdays you had some in
there fridays and saturdays so i had to
look at the schedule a lot of times
before i went up there sometimes i'd go
up to 8 30 and take a shower for an hour
and take my time and sing in the shower
it was amazing
i think back at those times i took
showers at the comedy store
in the daytime would take him to josh
wolfe's house in the morning
but at night his girlfriend would be
there the kids
i couldn't take a shower in their house
i would go to the comedy store and just
stay there the rest of the night
wow
but my point being that
there was a generation of comics i came
up with
that came out here and i saw them leave
one by one and each of them had an
excuse
until this day i like him whatever if i
see him i give him a hug but it's like i
lost respect for it for them you know
what i'm saying yeah yeah
you
you didn't like doing comedy like we
were talking about mcbettencourt anymore
nick call me the other day we had an
hour conversation wow and he goes i just
want to let you know and it's not that
you're quitting
it's that you took it out of your
itinerary to do something else yeah
and that's a beautiful thing those guys
that just quit now they gotta now
they're still doing comedy
in shitholes and they're saying that you
have to be gay to live in l.a that
everybody who's successful sucks dick oh
there's a thousands of comics out there
that'll tell you that because they used
to tell me to my face when i was a
feature act
and i'd work those little b rooms they
would tell me i used to i used to do
spots at the lab factory i wouldn't saw
jamie's dick really jamie's gay
stop he's 60 just had a [ __ ] kid
and he's gay because what are you a fat
[ __ ] magician get the [ __ ] out of
here
but you my friend got a lot of respect
for me and uh
i think people needed to know about you
i think people i saw your montreal
pictures from felicia
i think you do great work like i said
most people take a picture of me i'm
still a fat ugly dude when you take a
picture of me
i see the third thing i see that i see a
little bit of character in your pictures
yeah well look it's taking a picture of
you as you are and it's also i i like to
mix in who you are and who you want to
be like that's kind of the the point and
that's why those pictures those hallway
pictures they're surrounded by all the
headshots from all these comics and it's
like it i if if you
if you look at it this way i look at it
like those comics are propelling that
person forward you know like the next
generation they're pushing them up the
front line is your turn you know
and everybody that that performs in that
original room they had to earn that [ __ ]
to get there and uh when they go on
stage it is something special like they
walk up knowing like hey i'm a [ __ ]
paid regular like there's such a pride
in that at the store it's a really cool
thing to see that
and uh that
everyone can count on that when you go
there you go you know people gonna no
one's gonna walk and go huh hold on i
gotta let me check my my clipboard and
no no you just like people are going up
there and set themselves on fire right
hey dog
i'm a high school dropout i'm a felon
i'm a divorcee i got a kid i don't talk
to i got a new kid i got a wife i got my
life together and i gotta tell you other
things i don't have the one thing i do
have is
that all these comics could suck my dick
is that i'm a [ __ ] mitsy show a paid
regular i mean she made me that's in my
world guys
that's like [ __ ] carlo gambino
putting you into the [ __ ]
into the gotti family whatever that is
again be no crime family there was no
[ __ ] there was no tape there was no
assistant
i went up there i did three i came back
the next week and did 10 and that [ __ ]
made me a regular and knocked the air
out of me and my life has changed
ever since no matter how i feel about it
no matter how she feels and she's jewish
so you let you know my admiration goes
all the way back to [ __ ] israel with
these [ __ ] it wasn't for a jew
i wouldn't be here you know what i'm
saying if it wasn't for a jew at every
angle i wouldn't be it a jew wouldn't
have killed jesus jesus would have got a
second [ __ ] sequel
if jews
well you're gonna give me the paperwork
you're gonna sit there like a dozen bots
let's do this i'll go through three
months how many more stars you want to
eat tonight pick a number [ __ ] second
17. two more what we got in there these
are strong stars how many how many
milligrams earnest 125. oh you can't be
kidding me yeah you're going
for the murky waters of the underworld
yeah yeah and we've had what oh
so i like uh i'm uh the ultimate
lightweight like i feel 10
like no problem
oh yeah you're going to feel this
so this is we're going to end with
eating two two more
what the [ __ ] so what is this 14
whatever who gives a [ __ ] i would be
high for a week with just taking the
who gives you 15 stars and takes you to
popeye's chick not you me [ __ ] sucker
cause i love you you never take me to
popeye's chicken well i'm gonna take you
tomorrow
yeah because i love you [ __ ] that you
want another stuff no i got it i still
got a little bit of star left you got
the motorcycle what do you got out there
what's that oh no i got a car i got the
wheels but uh look i can take an uber if
this thing kicks in like i think it
might okay
worst thing happens
take a walk take a walk
at least making noises like half my
stomach is jello now from this [ __ ]
well it's a lot of jello star you like
jello somebody sent me a tape yeah i
gotta send it here on the show some i
can't believe his name david
he sent the tape on the podcast with lee
on the mushrooms
and he just took all the voices and just
put all these sound effects
from that podcast on a [ __ ]
35 minute i love it was that online can
we watch can we see listen to that email
me down the church podcast door oh my
god i gotta hit it so i gotta try how to
send it to my email and it was too big
so look at paul lee looks like he's
playing the [ __ ] trumpet over there
let me tell you there was an episode
where i i've never laughed so hard at
anything i i actually had to like edit a
recording of it to listen to it a bunch
of times where lee was so high it was
the night you guys were talking about uh
uh the the left turns were banned on
hollywood because that cut out people
from getting hookers right and and this
was where lee was so high this is the
most beautiful moment and you're talking
about you're like yeah they cut this off
so now you couldn't turn left and get a
hooker and league forgot that he didn't
have anything at stake like he wasn't
going to get hookers so he was so high
that he didn't realize that and he goes
those [ __ ] he was so
legitimately angry i've never in my life
laughed that hard he was like
[ __ ] like the greatest extra be
everybody's ringtone oh
he's a [ __ ] beauty i love it i love i
love getting that hive and and that's it
it's end i get high envy out of you lee
because i don't know how to get to that
safely oh well it's taking years and
years of training
oh he's a superstar
you know you know what i'm the other day
i remembered something
lee went to a jiu jitsu tournament
lee gave her the chance he went with a
rip gee
he had to roll up his pants because the
ghee was too long for him i hadn't i had
paws
we actually
you know my agents always ask me what
are they gonna put together like a web
series and i'm like listen
i have no web series for you what i have
is the educational lease i had that's
all i have for you a kid that was a
sweet kid he believed in society he
believed in life he thought everybody
was nice and [ __ ] and now
this guy had a vietnam vet that was a
clean
woman you know
i mean he had some guy from the wall
cleaning his house
this guy made a bed for a hooker one
night we told him hulk was on his way up
and i go it took you so long because i
had to make the bed who makes the bed
for a little bit
with aids on the back seat
i treat him with class those are great
yeah class you [ __ ] big dummy what
i'm gonna do with you
you're over there you're coming in mouth
and you swap spit with the [ __ ]
you filthy [ __ ] animal that's how you
get your resistance up
to what the [ __ ] say nothing happens to
you this is listen it's like a polio
yeah it's like listen you're talking
about your like immune system you come
in a prostitute's mouth and you swab
spit with her and call it like a dirty
louie look at you go to miami and jump
around for an hour those zika mosquitos
what happens if you don't survive the
dirty louie what happens
everybody survives with dirty little
that's always gonna be collateral your
[ __ ] own [ __ ] nails it out you know
what i'm saying it's like you know if
you've gotten to the point of needing a
dirty louie you haven't had like a woman
get come out of you for a while so it's
going to be like a really like old one
so what is this japanese now you thought
why do you always have to turn something
into dirty old you're the one who made
it the dirty louie louie
i don't know why he's a sweet person i
don't know what a dirty louie i didn't
know what dirty louie is but i i mean
i mean i sort of know now well i'm happy
that you know i love it is that did you
did you name it that or yeah it's a
dirty louie it's got a last guy in the
woods this is a thing louis over on 82nd
street park he used to get hookers
coming him out to make out with him and
then he grew he always told me he had a
sore throat what do you think
you're swapping spit with [ __ ]
hookers they suck 18 dicks a week and
you want to go over there and [ __ ]
you tell them you love them and
he's like no i come in their mouth and i
make out with them why would you do
something like that
some people's [ __ ] kids anyway this
show is brought to you by texture
my god
listen thanks to pizza we're all binge
eating thanks to netflix wall binge
watching but now with texture you can
start binge reading trust me it's all
about to be a thing when it comes to
magazines you know what you like and
with text it you get all the magazines
you want in one super convenient place
texture has completely reimagined
magazines re-image magazines giving you
the articles and stories you really want
all in one place plus interactive
features videos and recommendations just
for you the texture app lets you tap
into the world's most popular magazines
anytime anywhere any place using a
smartphone or a tablet breeze through
hundreds of favorite magazines including
back issues and pick the articles that
interest you the most
texture has made it easier for you to
find the articles you care about
i just don't read uh you know
cosmopolitan and uh
uh what's the other one national
geographic okay i just don't read these
things the text editorial team
recommends content for me and every day
plus i can dive deeper into personalized
collections let me tell you something
texture is phenomenal this is the
magazines that are in texture
mclean's mac world
red book they have espn the magazine
espn the magazine essence
coastal living they got rolling stone
right they got rolling stone on here the
hollywood reporter they got today's
parent they got u.s weekly they've got
women's health they've got
no rolling stone sorry yeah rolling
stone i know i see it in here they got
runner's world they got shape magazine
they got shutter bug they got new york
magazine they got oprah the magazine
listen it don't stop hitting so do me a
favor the best part is of this texture
is offering my listeners a free trial
right now when you go to texture.com
joey you'll gain immediate entry into
all the top magazines including back
issues and bonus video content listen
you're flying you're traveling you're in
your office you're making moves you need
to keep up with your magazines if you
like that stuff i'm not deterring you
you're reading you're opening up your
mind why stop because you're a man on
the move do me a favor start binge
reading for free right now when you go
to texture.com
joey again that's texture.com
joey the texture app is entirely digital
so it's super environmentally friendly
way to consume the best magazines and
articles plus you can share your
subscription with the whole family so
why [ __ ] around you know what i'm saying
that's number one lee i'm so glad they
had rolling stone too like that was i
was actually going to be bummed out if
they did not have it and they got it and
uh it's a great it sounds like a great
one well you know what i'm happy you
[ __ ] like it you know what i'm saying
maybe you'll go home and order it put it
on your things now
maybe we'll get through your own
magazines i don't [ __ ] devices put on
the right why are you throwing me off
here you know i'm having problems here
all the time listen not all ingredients
are created equal
fresh high quality ingredients taste
better and are better for you so it's
important
to know where your food comes from talk
about your you know when you go to
mcdonald's they don't tell you where
your food comes from they just give you
a burger it smells like a foot and
you're stoned so you take it and go eat
it listen
all i know is this my man lisa ayat's
been on blue apron now what's how many
pounds have you lost
i've lost like 12. i haven't i haven't
looked in the past week but it's been
amazing dude i love blue apron and what
did you cook okay so we cooked a bunch
of stuff recently we cooked um these
beef quesadillas which
like i used to put only cheese in
quesadillas but they we made this like
really great beef what else did we make
i made this roast pork i mean they're
called porchetta sandwiches and they had
this kale
like parmesan honey aioli how many times
how many meals do you have a week with
blue apron you get three recipes with
two servings on the two-person plan
that's what i'm on they have like the
family plan which gets more which
if and when paula moves in we'll
probably get that one because it's a lot
more meals because it's great they like
they literally so it's great because
like you're learning so they they always
like
lighten it up a little bit they're like
put one clove of garlic i'm always like
oh i'm gonna put like three cloves of
garlic in here but it's cool because you
like we made um like this we we made
this pasta that's what we made we made
this basil
pasta with chicken
and we made the sauce for it and like
with the whole tomato with the tomato
paste and the tomatoes and everything
and we like it just cool to learn how to
do it because they make the instructions
really easy
like
so the the trick i learned is they have
it set for like people who like maybe
like want to go to culinary school so
they're like okay so well this is going
cut this i can't do that i'm kind of
slow so i do all the prep first
and then i just look through and i look
because sometimes they'll say grab some
water so the only thing they don't give
you is like water oil water and oil and
pepper you said right yeah so that's it
so i'll get everything i need
and most things take under an hour to do
the whole thing it's great
and they're low calorie yeah like i
think it's i think it probably says
there's between five and 700
calories a meal most of them well i'll
tell you what you get all this for less
than ten dollars per meal and beauty of
it blue apron delivers the recipes along
with the pre-proportioned ingredients to
make your delicious home-cooked meal
blue apron knows that when you cook with
incredible ingredients you make
incredible meals so they set the highest
quality standards for their community
suppliers family-run farms fisheries and
ranches whether it's a japanese ramen
noodles or the wild caught alaskan
salmon or the heirloom tomato blue apron
is bringing you the best okay new
recipes are created weekly and they're
not repeated within a year so you choose
your meals from a variety of recipes or
let blue apron's culinary team surprise
you each meal comes with a step-by-step
easy to follow recipe card proportion
ingredients and can be prepared like lee
said in 40 minutes or less okay so do me
a favor stop messing around you're busy
you're trying to lose weight do me a big
favor what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna get
you three meals for free
with free shipping if you go to
blueapron.com
joey okay i'm giving you three meals
free with free shipping by going to
blueapron.com
joey you're gonna love how good it feels
and how good it tastes and how to create
incredible home-cooked meals with your
wife your nephew whoever you like so go
to blueapron.com don't wait again that's
blueapron.com joey what i'm going to do
is i'm going to give you three meals
gratis all right
blue apron a better way to cook what do
you think you're dealing with here
ladies and gentlemen don't forget
honor.com alpha brain 100 money back
guarantee they don't want the product
back whether you're looking for bats
kettlebells
uh hemp forest protein shroom tech sport
shroom tech immune listen they're
throwing heat over that on it i don't
know how to break down all the stuff i
haven't got what i'm telling you is i'm
giving you a tremendous deal you're
gonna go to hunter.com right now look at
the great selection that they have
you're gonna settle on something maybe
it's a shroom type maybe it's the new
bone maybe it's not the strong ball not
the new bone the strong bone maybe it's
the new mood maybe it's those that new
veggie mix that they sent me the lemon
lime [ __ ] tremendous whatever you
want check out and then there's a box
for a discount put in church boom
c-h-u-r-c-h i'm gonna give you 10 off
who's better than uncle joe you're right
so do me a favor blue apron.com
texture.com
on it.com that's your [ __ ] numbers
for the night all right i love you guys
we'll see you again wednesday night i
want to thank troy conrad a dear friend
i love you today i love you where can
they find you troy conrad uh you find me
on instagram troy conrad's with an s on
the end everything else just my name he
looks a bit he's got great pictures on
there every night setlist show
interesting guy that's why i had him on
have a great [ __ ] monday have a great
tuesday and we'll see you wednesday
[ __ ] stay black
you